Why were you looking at me?
So slide Jamie,
you made me nervous.
It made me nervous.
I like,
what is he doing?
Is he playing or we already live,
we're fucking live.
So,
um,
I tweeted something today that somebody
tweeted me or I read something that
somebody tweeted.
So I quoted it but it wasn't right.
God dammit.
That is pretty close that Donald Trump
will be 70 years old and six days.
So it is seven months in,
six days,
seven months.
Seven year olds,
70 years old.
Seven months and six days.
Almost seven year old years old.
Seven months and seven days when he
becomes the president.
And he won by 77 electoral votes from
seven electors.
Wow.
Yeah.
Happy seventh anniversary of the jre
too.
This is basically it.
Yeah.
Pretty close.
Mara.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
I,
this is crazy.
So a lot of sevens 97.
Why are you obsessed with seven?
It's like why is your sure
came from the jre one time we were
talking about how we were in a
simulation theory and how everything's
made out of ones and Zeros.
And I said something like,
I'm going to hack it.
I'm ready to start saying sevens or
something.
I can't even remember what it was.
But it's all from that.
So this is your shirt that has all
seven.
It's,
yeah,
it's a made from seventh.
This is a,
is it just a bunch of different colors?
Sevens,
yeah.
To make the artwork and this
sweatshirts,
the death squad seven 11 shirt.
Why seven though?
And I know it came from the jre from a
long time ago.
I Dunno.
I Dunno where,
I have no idea why.
Imagine,
imagine if that's proof.
If like people look back on this and
they realize they're,
there really is a simulation.
You tap into it by make,
you can make things happen with your own
brain.
I think the older I get,
the more crazy I get.
Cause I've believe it more,
you know,
like I start feeling like I'm,
I go crazy sometimes.
I don't necessarily think it's crazy.
I think it's crazy to think that it's
impossible that it's a simulation.
It was like,
just think about what we're doing.
Right.
Just think about the uh,
just just if no one was in his room,
but us just for,
obviously we're doing a podcast,
but if no one was in this room other
than us,
we're looking at each other through our
eyeballs with thinking about it inside
of our brains.
We're assuming that we're all operating
in the same area.
I'm assuming you see what I see.
I'm assuming like what I think of as the
reality around you is what you,
but I have zero evidence other than
photos and again,
I'm looking at those photos and my
interpretation of those photos.
Who knows what you're saying.
I have no idea what you're saying.
Then we're dealing with language,
trying to formulate words that match
your thoughts and they almost never do.
Like that's one of the number one
problems that people have with
politicians.
Right?
We know in some weird way that their
words and their thoughts are not in
sync.
Like we want your words and your
thoughts to be in sync,
but it's fucking hard to do man.
It's like one of the unspoken things
about being a person is how fucking
difficult it is to get your thoughts to
come out the way you're feeling them
with your words.
It's very hard to do.
You can make something that's so,
so eloquent and with the UV articulate
and it would be amazing to read and it's
a quote that people might have on their
fucking instagram page for the next
decade,
but did it really represent what you
were thinking or was it just a clever
collection of words that strikes in
effect?
So when people are just talking,
not nothing like reading someone's
writing or something,
but just talking like,
man,
it's fucking hard to get your brain like
what's coming out of your brain to be
represented by your voice.
That alone is way weirder than the fact
that this is all fake.
That's way weirder than a simulation.
Right?
Just communicating just shit we totally
take for granted.
Then the fact that you could do it
online,
I mean how many he's fucking dudes have
these youtube channels and gals have
these youtube channels with have fucking
millions of people paying attention to
them.
And it seems like for the most part,
like Hollywood hasn't even figured it
out yet.
Like they've dabbled in MP,
they've given people shows like that.
Adam ruins everything guy.
Right.
He was a youtube pass.
Oh Great.
He's fantastic.
It's funny fucking show too.
He's really good at it and he's a Gamer.
He twitches all the time.
And he said he's on a marathon the other
day watching it.
But then there's other people that are
bad,
like the guy from yesterday that that
was a thrown off the delta airline and
it happened with that.
He said,
here's what happened.
And then we found out that he's done
this before he goes,
he pretty much goes on airplanes and
trolls and he,
he uh,
he counts in Arabic like 10,
nine,
eight,
seven and does shit like that.
And he's done it before.
There's videos of him doing it before
say pretty much just freaks everybody
out.
Like,
why is this guy counting down?
You know?
It's like if anyone was on an airplane
and counting down and would still be
weird.
Yeah.
We need to like for pranks we need to
figure out like what's a prank and what
is fucking with people's lives for a
short amount of time.
Yeah.
Cause the only,
the only way like it goes legit is if
the people of good nature and at the end
the,
they sign off on a release.
Right?
Right.
They'll sign off on a release for
youtube videos as well.
If there's any money at attached to it,
I would say yes,
but I'm not a lawyer.
I wonder.
Yeah,
I wonder how that works.
But when you're scaring the shit out of
people like that on a plane,
like you could really fuck with their
head.
Like,
yeah.
I mean I know you're a young fucking
crazy guy who's fearless,
who does those kinds of videos and you
think it's funny,
but you got to realize it might be like
some grandma behind you.
There might be a five year old girl.
There might be,
you know,
dude who
has like some serious tension issues.
It's not nice.
You know,
it's,
it's not funny enough for,
for us to accept that.
It's like,
but these boundaries get tested
sometimes by,
you know,
really in a lot of ways,
brave performers.
It's a brave thing to do.
It's not smart.
It's not a good thing to do.
It's not thoughtful,
but two,
it's hard to do that.
It's hard to go on a fucking plane and
start counting down from 10 and Arabic
and hope that nobody beats you to death
before you,
you know,
you say,
Hey,
I'm just fucking around.
Just a youtube video.
But it's awesome.
Gross as fuck.
When you sell it at yourself as like,
oh my God,
they,
they're doing this to me.
They're so racist.
When you're kind of,
you're,
you're trying to get that,
you know,
you're baiting them and you've got proof
that you've done it before.
Yeah.
That's not cool.
It's gross.
That's gross.
But we're talking about it.
So he wins.
I mean really man,
it just seems like people want to figure
out a way to get in,
you know?
And uh,
there's so many people,
like we were talking about like that
Adam Guy are so many other ones that
have just a giant segment of the viewing
population already.
You know,
there's a lot of these channels that
people have that people are just
addicted to like listening to these
people talk about shit and for you to
try to break in and make your own
channel.
It's a,
it's weird,
right?
It's like there's still people that are
doing it and then the network way,
there's still shows that are on network
television that,
that work like that there prank shows
and shit like that.
Most of them are fake luckily,
you know,
on Youtube and even in real life or
they're,
you know,
fake reality,
whatever,
where they're half real.
You see too much these days.
Like there's too much coming in.
I watched this guy sucker punch of
Grandma,
Oh God,
a video where this old lady was behind
this young dude and she was apparently
bothering him.
And so he turns,
there are other cash register line,
he turns and sucker punches or a full on
in the face.
It just knocks her dead and she falls
back and no one does anything about it.
It's really weird.
The cashier freezes up.
The guy behind her who's an old guy
freezes up and this no one knows what to
do.
It's weird.
I shouldn't have seen it.
I was like,
why do I,
why?
Why do I want to know if there's a
circumstance where some young guy feels
like he gets sucker punched some looks
like 80 year old lady and I'm not
kidding.
She's like white haired and,
and it doesn't look fake.
It's not that Shit's the shit that bugs
me the most.
And it's just,
it's just these kids now,
you know,
they,
they have no parents.
I saw,
I saw bieber the other day,
had a horrible incident with Bieber and
it was one of the worst things.
I wish I'd never saw my life cause I
used to always kind of like root for him
a little,
you know,
like he seemed like a nice guy,
especially after the roast.
He seemed like a cool guy down to earth.
But man,
how he treated this old guy and like how
he was treating the staff of this place
I was at.
It was one of the worst things I ever
saw.
It I had to leave normal me would be
recording,
Oh let's take settle this tmz or do
something crazy like that.
It was so gross.
I just wanted to get out of there.
I deleted all my tweets walk cause I was
live tweeting.
Why was there a beginning?
But then it got so bad that I just
deleted all my tweets and I was like,
then he yelled at me and it,
cause I had this dolphin hat on and he
goes,
hey,
you like dolphins man,
you love dolphins bro.
And like doing shit like that to me.
And I'm just like,
I go,
yeah,
I like the fuck dolphins dude.
Like I just start yelling at him.
I went crazy.
He got a little crazy right there.
Yeah,
yeah,
true story.
And you could ask my girlfriend when he
like he got quiet after that for like
three minutes.
And then like the table of guys that he
was with were just staring at me and
when I was walking out,
he just screams all of garden.
True story,
I promise you.
Okay.
So now I'm like,
does he know who I am?
And that's why he was fucking with me.
Did he find out who I was after I yelled
at him and he shut up or what?
But we're live with that question.
I don't want to ever know the answer to
that question.
But the horrible thing about it was that
it,
he was really treating people like shit.
Like that's super unfortunate to hear
him.
This old guy was staring down like,
please don't talk to me anymore.
Please don't talk to me.
Like you could tell he was just,
what is he like 21 or something.
And I know I didn't even think it was
him.
We thought it was like 14 year old kids
for like the first half of the time we
were there.
We were like,
wait a second,
that tattoo,
it looks familiar.
Then I was googling Justin bieber back
of his neck.
Don't ever do.
That's gross.
And then,
and then it was the exact same tattoos
like wings and like this like weird
writing.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
That really is him.
Hmm.
How many people,
and this is a legitimate honest
question,
how many people have ever gone through
the fire of becoming famous when you're
young and come out?
Okay.
Has Anybody Jodie foster?
Right.
But I don't know her.
She might be crazy as fuck.
Right?
She's a really good acts as a cutter.
She knows man.
Who knows?
She was really famous,
really young.
Like how old was Jodie foster in taxi
driver?
I want to go like super young.
I want to go like teenage years.
19 I'd say 19 what would you say?
Oh,
1550 wow.
She played a 12 year old.
She was 13 when the movie premiered.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Shit.
Holy Shit.
She's laid a prostitute at the tender.
Oh my God.
Jesus fucking Christ and know that it's
true,
dude.
They made their play a prostitute at 12
years old.
What a mind fuck that must be.
You can't do that anymore,
right?
No,
you can't do that anymore.
Do you remember in that Movie Cape Fear?
Yeah,
that's her dude.
That's insane.
You remember in that Movie Cape Fear
when Robert Deniro had a,
what was her name?
Juliette.
Juliette Lewis.
Yeah.
Suck his fingers.
Wasn't that in that movie?
I don't know.
Was that that movie Maya?
Just a freak might just making shit up.
I F I have this vague memory of some
really weird twisted seduction scene.
Yeah.
She's sucking his finger.
Little cross eyed almost dude fucking
bangs
dude.
How old was she was supposed to be like
seven to 17 she was 17 when he did this.
Oh my God.
So that's the locally when it says
that's what it says.
Oh Daily Mail.
Okay.
They wouldn't lie.
17 year old even shared a kiss and a
thumb sucking and the scene.
What to know?
That's dark dude.
Cause Dinero had to be like deep in his
forties then that's weird.
17 that should be illegal.
That's a loophole.
Yeah,
that's a loophole.
It just,
because it's in a movie,
like you can't fuck that kid.
Like probably say you probably shouldn't
have a 17 year old sucking your thumb.
But my point was that like this was a
long time ago and we didn't look at
things the same way a long time ago as
we do today.
It's more evidence that there's some
weird gigantic shift in the way people
are recognizing and understanding the
consequences of things like child abuse,
you know,
or things like that.
Man,
that's weird.
I saw a creepy guy at the mall the other
day looking at the cub scouts or boy
scouts did.
They were wrapping presence.
Maybe he just used to be a boy scout
himself.
Well the asked for the days it was
limber.
I would say the same thing if it wasn't
rubbing his dick against the railing.
He sure.
Yeah.
Maybe just barely get stand up.
How he was three stories up and just
rubbing his dick left and right on this
railing,
staring straight down.
Did you hear about the security guard at
the NFL game the other day?
No.
Caught on video jacking off to a
cheerleader right in front of them.
Oh,
Jesus.
Watch this video.
It's fucking crazy.
Oh No,
no,
no.
See in his pants he said,
I believe it.
I've seen too much.
I don't need to see that.
Jesus Christ right in the middle of
everyone.
There's people like so crazy.
It must be just getting his rocks off in
the biggest way possible.
I'm off the freak.
What a security guard.
Fucking what a world dude.
I wonder if that's a real yeah,
again,
but it's real.
So my thought was that this,
um,
this bebe kid,
you know,
I mean,
has anybody ever gone,
well,
I guess people have gone through that
and become more friendly,
but I had a friend of mine,
or just worked with another dude who was
famous the time he was young and they
did a television show together and it's
just like,
whoa,
they have this.
He was like,
I think that someone who grows up
famous,
unless you're like some really cool
person that figures it out,
they have this attitude that everyone's
supposed to just like them and that
they're like above everyone else.
They have this idea in their head that
it's almost impossible to break if
you've known that your whole life,
your whole life from tom or little,
everybody's treating you like you're
super spreadsheet without,
you really have an earn it so much.
The casio kind of earn it with your
talent,
you know?
That's a very talented,
well,
how about like Ricky Schroeder,
who's my friend who was famous when he
was really,
really,
really young silver spoons?
Yeah.
Riding a train,
had an arcade game in his house.
Did.
He was in that movie,
the champ.
I watched that when I was a little kid
and made me cry.
That was a harsh movie.
He was fucking good man.
Like anybody that gets famous,
that young has a crazy challenge in
front of them for like figuring out
life.
I couldn't imagine that beaver kids been
famous since he was like,
what?
12 or something?
And to be honest,
he was 21 year old drunk like yeah,
blackout drunk.
He was that drunk.
Well,
think about how fucked up you get.
Oh yeah.
When you're full 42 and imagine.
But I've never been like a,
almost like a bully,
like yelling.
He was yelling at people instead of like
don't leave me alone.
And then being a dick,
he was actually looking and yelling and
pointing out people and talking shit
about the restaurant and you know,
it's fine.
Anyways,
all those things,
the alcohol,
that's a big factor for sure.
Being a boy.
Yeah,
no,
this is the thing about being dudes
being the dude is a lot like having a
car,
a car that's just like a little too fast
for the road.
Like you're always pushing it like that.
That's what being a dude is.
You know,
especially guys growing up around a
bunch of other guys,
they're all competing wrestling and shit
out,
dude in each other.
I like.
It becomes,
if they feed off of each other people,
you know,
people feed off each other and men don't
have enough outlets for natural male
behavior you just told you shouldn't
think like that.
You shouldn't be like that.
You know?
You should be more aware,
be more kind.
That's all nice and you're right 100%
but you got to deal with the fucking
biology of your body.
Your body wants to smash shit and fuck
things.
It's what it's built for.
And so if you don't feed it,
if you don't give it some sort of
exertion,
it's going to play tricks on you.
It's going to over ramp stressful
situations.
Gonna make you more upset at things more
easy.
It's going to make you more prone to
getting pissed off in traffic.
All those things like that has to be
addressed.
Like people have to figure that out.
You can't just ask boys to just be be
better.
Just,
you know,
you've got to give them like some sort
of biological tools.
And this,
this,
I will obviously I wasn't there,
you know,
and if I was there,
I probably would have had probably the
same problems with it that you did,
but I can't imagine being that fucking
kid.
Yeah.
I can't imagine being that girl.
What's her name?
Um,
Lindsay Lohan.
She makes me sad every time I see her,
she makes me sad.
I see those pictures.
I'm like,
this poor kid is fucking swimming in
space with no connector.
It's just like she's gone.
She's a part of this giant machine of
movies and TV and publicity and fame and
covers of magazines and,
and she was a baby,
a baby when she got into it.
She didn't know shit.
And that,
that formed her whole life.
And people like,
Oh boo hoo.
Poor her with all her money.
Listen to me,
that money doesn't mean shit.
If you're crazy and you're smoking
crack,
it doesn't mean shit.
It doesn't mean anything.
Your life is hell.
Yeah.
You don't have to worry about food.
Okay,
so your life is hell and you don't have
to worry about food.
It's one notch better than you.
Life is hell and you're starving to
death,
but it's still,
your life is a hell.
Paris Hilton's holding it together.
She kind of pulled away from fame,
which might've been like a really smart
thing to do.
She might've like felt the repercussions
of all that hate because nobody puts
themselves out there in a position more
so than someone who becomes a reality
star.
You know?
Because when you become a reality star,
you're sort of admitting that you don't
do anything right.
If you're just a reality star,
you,
you don't do anything.
You're not singing,
you're not reading books that you wrote.
You're not like doing public readings of
a book.
You're not doing it.
You're just being a person,
right?
Everybody can fucking be a person,
man.
It's,
it's one thing if you have a reality
show,
reality show about Kanye West.
Well that's Kinda interesting because
who the fuck gets to be Kanye West?
Only Kanye West.
So if it was them following Kanye round,
it would make more sense.
But it's not,
it's them just live in their life.
It's fucking genius and a lot of ways
because they figured out by just kind of
like being outrageously extravagant and
opulent with their money and uh,
by you know,
constantly mixing and drama.
They'd been able to stay on TV for like
11 fucking years.
It's,
it's jeans and a lot of ways look at,
ain't any worse than a lot of that
shitty fucking shows around tv tonight.
Some terrible ass show on TV.
Why is that worse?
Cause it's,
it's terrible and no one wrote it like,
cause that what it is that the problem?
It's worse cause no,
if you like,
we'll leave shifts.
You have made this up and it was
terrible.
It'd be all right.
Like as to why is it okay?
There's the equal level of terrible all
over television that nobody cares about.
But we care because it's just a bunch of
people live in their life and we can all
do that.
You know,
if you have the kind of money to come on
young Jamie hit the lotto and all of a
sudden got a 500 foot yacht and started
bawling hard Dan Bilzerian style all
over instagram,
all the Jordans and following you with a
camera,
they could absolutely make a fucking
reality show about that 100%.
Absolutely.
It could be young Jamie freaking out,
complete to way too much pussy,
not knowing what to do and we have to
pull them aside and go,
dude,
you got to calm down so much.
Shit hit me up.
But you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
all you have to do is create a
circumstance,
create a circle.
If you're just a regular person,
you know,
I mean,
that's all they are.
They're just regular people.
They're not,
um,
it's not like they're working for the
Cirque de Solei and they have this
insane physical stuff that they have to
do and they're working on it constantly
and like,
wow,
this is fascinating.
I've never,
never thought of how they prepare for
this.
But yeah,
you'd managing it'd be pretty rigorous.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
Regular bitches going shopping,
eating salads like oh my God.
And I told him like what they,
the way they get around,
I just like to make a charity or
something,
you know,
charity.
Yeah.
Nicole Richie,
charity of small animals.
Forgotten.
There's something up on my instagram
page right now.
I wanted to mention this because it's
going on until the end of December is a,
a very cool company that makes epsom
salts.
If you go to fight for the forgotten,
oh actually water for orange water
for.org
rather.
Uh,
and then forward slash fight for the
forgotten boy.
That was a marble mouth delivering.
So I'll say that again.
Water four,
the number four.
So water,
the number four.org.
That's the organization that Justin
Wren,
our friend works with and Justin is
building wells in the Congo.
He's fucking beautiful person.
But anyway,
they raised a ton of money so far and
it's going to provide clean water to a
lot of people.
Um,
water for.org
forward slash fight for the forgotten is
it really?
100% beautiful story.
That guy's an amazing person.
And what he's done I think is just,
it's so selfless and loving and
inspiring.
And I think people like him doing shit
like that.
Oh,
I'm gonna cry.
People like him doing shit like that
literally can change the world.
That guy,
Justin wren can change the world just by
being so loving and caring.
I mean,
he goes down there and spend months and
months at a time and the Congo and he's,
he's gotten malaria three fucking times.
I mean,
he's like,
he keeps getting it and he's going to
be,
I mean,
it's still like the racking his body.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Such a beautiful person,
man.
And he's a heavyweight fighter for Bella
tour and the whole things can,
he used to fight in the UFC.
He's a fucking animal.
I mean,
he's just such a freaky dude.
It's like you meet people like that and
you know,
Oh,
I guess I'm a piece of shit.
I've just,
I'm not that Nice.
I'm not going to the Congo.
I'll send you some money,
man,
but I'm not going to the fucking Congo.
I'm not getting malaria.
Um,
no,
I can't really,
at least I hope I don't.
But anyway,
um,
I don't know how we got on that.
I stone text you that you should work
with big brother.
Do you remember that?
Oh,
well let me explain this though because
I just remembered.
So all of it's,
I guess all the profits for the whole
month of December go to this.
So if you buy epsom salts from these
people,
um,
episode episode,
that's the company eap soak.
I use epson salts all the time.
First of all,
from my isolation tank.
Second of all,
just a nice hot bath.
It feels really good.
It's really good for your body and it
helps your body absorb magnesium.
You absorb magnesium through your skin.
You can,
you know,
with this,
with epsom salt baths,
really good for him,
man.
Get a gargle too.
Like after massage parlor,
what you,
what are you doing?
Blowing guys?
The massage.
Pawn the fuck dude.
But um,
the uh,
epsom salt baths,
uh,
or like super underrated man.
If you've got like some tension and
shit,
throw some epsom salts in the tub.
Just kind of,
Ooh,
Ooh.
I don't know why.
Right.
Have you flood it lately?
I have it in my basement.
I now floating mother fucker.
Dude.
It's where figure shit out.
Probably too much.
I'm trying.
I'm thinking too much for sure.
I think about too many different things.
Um,
so,
uh,
I'm trying to narrow my focus more.
That's one of the reasons why I cut back
in the UFC.
I was like,
I'm narrowing my focus.
I think,
you know,
just trying to do things that I think
are a,
that I'm compelled to do,
you know?
Absolutely.
You seem like you've been enjoying
outside stuff more like archery and
stuff like that.
Hunting.
We'll do it that come from,
cause you never had that before.
I know.
Well,
it came from the first time I did it for
first time I went hunting and was
successful and I was like,
oh,
okay.
I get it now.
Like this is,
oh,
this is nuts.
Like what a crazy thing to do.
And it's also in a weird,
odd way,
there's a helplessness that you feel
when you were in nature that I think is
very almost psychedelic because like
when you go and you not even now like
hunting,
um,
I'm just talking about go to a place
where there's no cell phone signal at
all.
Go deep into the woods and you will feel
vulnerable as fuck.
You feel vulnerable and then you start
thinking,
Holy Shit,
there's bears out here.
There's fucking mountain lions out here
for real.
Like I'm in there where they live.
This is where they live.
This isn't like a mountain lion in Santa
Monica on some,
you know,
freak incident.
This is like,
you're going to where they live and
people don't live.
What's your hunting tech game like?
Do you have like night vision goggles?
Like all the coolest stuff so you can
see the bear?
I don't have anything.
Well you don't go out at night.
The only thing you do at night,
it's like stay around the camp,
stay around the campfire.
But this even nights,
weird man,
we had a deer come into our camp once
and uh,
in the middle of the night and then
realize it was around people and he
starts stomping on the ground and
hoofing.
It was weird.
I barely heard it.
The other guys had to remind me of it,
but it's just animals do come into
people's tents.
Bears do.
That's what gets scary is big bears,
especially when they're starving.
Big bears that are starving.
We'll take some fucking chances.
And one of [inaudible] friends,
he his first hunt ever,
he was attacked in his tent by a 500
pound predatory black bear.
His friend shot the bear and hit him.
So shot him in the wrist and then the
bear ran out of that tent,
ran into another tent.
He's shot at in the other tent,
a 500 pound predatory black bear.
Just the,
just the power that that thing possesses
is so beyond any of our comprehension.
Like when you see their bodies,
you see a bear's body and you think of a
500 pound bear.
What this thing would have 500 pound dog
could do to you,
right?
Just think of that,
A 500 pound dog then,
have you ever seen like a baby bear
wrestle a dog?
It's fucking hilarious.
They,
it's like Habib Neuroma,
madoff wrestling your grandmother.
This bear just throws this fuck dog
around like at eight shit.
It's a little cub as a little baby bear.
Look,
look at this.
Look the,
the dog keeps fucking with them.
The bears way smaller.
Them the bears like,
all right,
pitch.
You want to get crazy?
All right,
let's get crazy.
So they start going to war and the bear,
the bear whips him to the ground.
They can put,
the dog keeps fucking with it.
Look at this.
Boom,
look at,
hey,
we have some around.
Wow Dude.
He just throws him around.
He's way smaller than that dog and the
dog is like,
oh no,
what have I done?
Look at this.
Boom,
bitch,
boom.
Side control like the bear can do shit
that dog can't do.
The doc had only bite,
but that bear has ridiculous power in
those arms.
Show that last 15 seconds.
Again,
look,
he throws him,
he uses his hips like look,
go back a little bit.
This bear is like a fucking judo champ.
Like lunch.
This is like some Cairo per easy and
shit.
Look,
boom.
He just throws him around.
Boom.
Seriously stocky.
Rex throws him around.
That bail is,
that's like Daniel cormier that bear,
he was his,
his hips man,
like instinctively uses his hips.
And now imagine one of those that's 500
pounds and wants to eat.
You.
Imagine what the fucking sheer terror of
that would be.
So that's not a good explanation for why
I like to do it,
but I like to do it just cause it's um,
it's nature.
I think it's like a fucking vitamin.
I think it's like a battery.
I think it's like a,
uh,
an experience that once you tap into it,
just being out there in nature,
it makes you understand what life is
better.
It makes you understand the world
It,
you understand this.
Just the fact that this is just some
weird living patch that's on the surface
of a planet mean the all the,
all those things like need to get
exposed to you and like chunks in order
for you to really truly absorb it.
Like you could see like Mount Everest or
some shit.
You could see it in a video and you're
like,
wow,
pretty cool,
but I don't think you're really seeing
it.
I think that's bullshit.
I think you're just seeing it all the
flat image,
a lifeless flat image.
But if you were there and you could take
it all in and you're,
you're,
I understand the perspective and you get
the immense nature of what you're,
you're in front of this fucking insanely
huge mountain,
then I think you'll,
you'll experience it until you,
until you go there.
I bet you don't feel it.
So I think that's the same with that.
You know,
it's like seeing a band that you don't
think is that awesome.
But then you see them live and you're
like,
holy shit man,
they fucking killed it.
Like Chicago rules.
Yeah,
no data.
But one of my first nights when we,
uh,
we first went camping,
I was almost immediately aware of it.
I was like,
wow,
this is a totally different feeling out
here.
Like you,
when you're in a city,
you feel like we're all kinda like
pretty relaxed.
Like,
this is where we live.
You know?
Hey,
uh,
you want to meet for lunch?
Yeah.
What do you want to go?
Let's go to that spot.
Okay.
Is it on Ventura?
Yeah,
let's go,
you know,
norm on Blah,
blah,
blah.
There's nothing like that.
When you're in the woods,
when you're in the woods,
everywhere you're walking,
you're like,
okay,
there's a bear over there.
No,
there's a mount mine over here.
No.
Is it deer over there?
Like where are the life forms?
Where the lifeforms,
where's the ones that I want to eat and
where's the ones that might want to eat
me?
Where are these fucking things
stressful?
It's very stressful,
but beautiful.
It's beautiful.
It's not stressful in that like you're
not really worried constantly of bears,
but they're fucking real,
like,
bears aren't a myth.
The real,
you know you're going and you know
you're going to where they live.
Mountain lions are real.
They're real.
I mean,
there's a giant fucking species.
It's a giant cat to 150 pound cat.
It lives in the forest and kill Shit
every day.
It's an expert at killing shit and it's
as big as you.
And if you've run into it,
you might be fucked.
He might not be,
but tell us like some Damon that was
like some demon that got summoned here
from another world and most of the time
it only eight deer and only consumed
dear to keep itself alive.
But every now and then,
every now and then it's snatches up.
A school child just pulls,
pulls it kid out of a fucking one of
those little swing sets and hops over
the fence with it before anybody can do
anything.
Like holy shit that happens,
man.
There was this video I saw yesterday
where this girl found
this like baby bunny.
She's like,
oh my gosh,
it's so cute.
And she's like petting it.
She put it down and the second she puts
it down,
this bird just comes out of nowhere and
picks it up and now hawk,
Hawk,
Hawk and jacked it.
It's fucked up.
You see the one where they got the night
vision of the owl flying in and Jack in
the hawk?
No,
we think it's a hawk.
We don't know what it is.
Might be a pigeon.
I don't know shit about birth people.
Mike,
Joe Rogan.
Todd Todd was a hawk.
There's a,
so it's a night vision and uh,
let's take a security cam and as the,
the owl flying in,
you see its eyes closer and closer and
closer.
And then check this out.
Watch this.
I look off in the distance.
See that?
Those are the eyes.
Oh Wow.
Watch it.
Call Man.
Look at this dude.
Wow.
Watch this.
Boom.
Holy Shit.
Now what kind of bird is that?
Look at it liquid to look at its face.
It kind of looks like a raptor,
right?
Might Be Falcon.
Right?
You know what though?
It might just be because it's night
vision.
It doesn't have that big of a beak.
What do you think it is,
Jamie?
Maybe some sort of or,
Huh?
It seems like a,
yeah,
it seems like a raptor,
right?
Like right there that looks like a
murderous little bird so that he got
murdered by another murderer,
that his eyes are for each other.
But watch how he gets him to,
he kicks him.
He gets low.
Bam.
So crazy dude.
The power that those things have and
their jaws are in their claws rather.
You mean?
I don't,
I don't think there's a way you could
ever understand what it would be like to
have a giant hand.
Like it's probably as strong as like a
person's hand and it's underneath the
bird and it's got knives on the end of
it and they just slots.
Imagine if you had some Bass Freddy
Kruger clause and that's what you do.
Just grab things and squish him.
Punched through him.
I mean think about how fucking Bananas
Flying Raptors are.
They're just big enough where they can't
kill us.
Judge big enough.
Just a little too small.
She'll little too small to kill us.
But if eagles could kill us,
like if eagles,
like the sides of buses,
we'd be fucks.
Ville would've never invented the wheel.
They would just jacked us and
extinction.
We'd be hiding in little holes in the
fucking hills,
would try to find anti eagle technology.
That would be our number one concern.
Kill the eagles.
Do.
That's a dragon is a dragon.
Who knows,
man,
maybe there were bigger raptors and they
killed him off.
Holy Shit.
There was,
there was one from New Zealand,
there was that.
We've talked about this.
I feel like fairly recently I read
something about this and I might have
brought it up,
but there was a rat.
Yeah we did.
There's an eagle in New Zealand,
I think it's called the Haas Eagle or
something like that,
but it's,
it was fucking enormous and people
killed it off and it lived in New
Zealand.
I think it had something ridiculous like
a 14 foot wingspan.
Wow.
And they,
they do think that it's entirely
possible that think this thing killed
people.
That's one of the reasons why the New
Zealand people killed it off.
Cause it was like in the 14 hundreds or
some shit.
They killed it off.
You find anything on it?
Yeah,
they think that there's a video of a
Golden Eagle snatching a kid.
Okay.
That's fake.
But they were thinking it was one of
those eagles black what people were and
weren't sure if it was fake or not.
Oh.
So when people weren't sure it was fake,
they thought maybe it was like a few of
those things still left in the wild.
But it's in New Zealand.
Right.
That was that video from New Zealand to,
and that's what this is like a debunking
video.
Oh,
geographic about it.
But it talks about those eagles.
I'm trying to find some stats on it.
Speaking of debunking,
did you hear all the crazy shit that's
going on with the snopes,
but you know that website snopes,
you're always thinking,
well this is where like really
reasonable website and for sure you
know,
if I go to them they'll have the answer.
The people own it or fucking freaks.
Matt for sure.
Do you know the story?
No.
I don't know.
I guess his wife and married a porn star
who is a,
also a escort,
an online escort.
Who is,
what's her name?
I don't know dude.
This is,
this is the guy apparently just divorced
his wife and started bawling out of
control.
He got it.
I got a bunch of cash and decided to
marry this Gal.
And now,
uh,
but as a,
there's also like some anti Bush stuff
about this too.
It's like someone,
someone in that group was involved in
uh,
some,
um,
anti Republican fundraising type
activity or something along those lines,
right?
Wasn't it,
you know,
Jamey,
what does it say I'm looking at anyway,
point is these just is just people like
everybody has been saying that there's
this democratic lean towards the truth,
like editorializing the truth on some of
those sites like snopes.
Like how much of this is like you,
are you absolutely sure,
like how am I,
how you've done a little bit of research
and come to your own conclusions.
Like how like vetted is this stuff,
who's in charge and then you find out,
well,
this is the people in charge.
These people are just freaks balling out
of control.
Marian hookers.
Did they find this out?
The facebook fake news thing happened.
Is that it?
Yes,
because those people were part of the
team that was supposed to clean up the
fake news.
And then there's a new thing that was
supposed to be out today as a new tool
that they think is going to be able to
figure out fake news.
We're fucked.
It's awful.
We're Fox folks.
People could just make shit up.
Did you see that crazy times?
Uh,
adobe released photoshop for sound.
I don't know if he saw this video and or
shopping for sound,
but what it can do is it can take,
like,
you can just say one sentence,
I love Tacos.
Oh,
we showed that.
We talked about it.
Didn't have a good clip to find it
because it didn't come up at the right
time,
but,
well,
we had a pretty decent clip.
There was one,
we showed a sentence.
It was pieced together from other stuff.
Yeah,
man.
Do you think that's been available
before they've announced this to the
public on this big giant announcement
party?
Oh yeah.
Right.
I would
imagine that that's the kind of
technology that you would take.
It would take a long time to work on.
But are you saying like is it being used
by nefarious sources?
I didn't sit in a farrier,
but I mean it's not there yet.
You know what I think about all that
stuff,
the,
those,
that kind of thinking.
I think that technology is improving so
quickly and I don't,
I don't necessarily think that the
people who are working for the u s
government are the ones that are 100% in
control of the information to get that
gets released.
Like these people that are constantly
innovating and creating all these new
products and these new technologies,
they're not all working for the
government.
They're just not.
Right.
So this idea that like the government
has some stuff way before we do.
Probably not today.
No.
Today I think it's a fucking river
filled with salmon that are covered in
baby oil and you can't grab one of these
motherfuckers in there.
Whoa.
They're flying by you.
That's what I think.
I think shit's changing so quick,
so fast that that's why all these leaks
and all these different things that
pertain to elections and changing
people's ideas are happening so quickly.
Like I don't even know if we understand
how nutty this is while it's happening
to us.
That's what that is.
That's what the fake the new tool to
visualize how fake news is spread.
Oh,
the tool to visualize how it's spread.
Yeah.
It's spread to Republicans.
You know?
It is.
It's like South Park.
They retweet stuff.
They don't vet the soda from Democrats
do.
Everybody does it.
It's like there was a,
there was an article recently that said
that people who are conservative are
much more likely to be fooled by fake
news,
but it was probably written by liberal,
so who the fuck knows?
Is it weird to you that Alex Jones seems
like he's blown the fuck up in the last
couple of years?
It's not weird.
Like my mom knows who Alex Jones is now.
It's weird.
People think that I'm somehow ducking
him that I don't want to have him on my
podcast.
I would love to have Alex on my
podcasts.
People don't know.
Like I have a very good relationship
with Alex Jones.
I love him.
He's my friend.
I hug him every time I see him,
I'm happy to see him.
I liked that guy a lot and he's crazy
and he's not all crazy,
but he's crazy.
But he's a good guy telling you.
He's like,
Alex Jones is a great fucking guy.
He stresses though.
Oh yeah,
he's freaks.
He freaks.
You know he needs a guy like me right
next to him all the time.
That's what it needs.
Like Alex Jones needs someone to go,
Alex,
Oh God.
Are you sure that the elites are going
to kill everybody off so they can live
forever?
Are you fucking sure?
Because if you not sure he got to stop
saying it.
You know he needs someone that's right
there.
Like I really think the problem with
like conspiracy theories is they feel so
good.
They feel great.
Like when you,
you think you really have footage of the
loch ness monster.
Holy Shit.
You feel good.
It doesn't matter if nobody wants to
blow me when I get to work,
I'm going to rock the world.
You know?
I think people who a are constantly
searching for conspiracies.
Everywhere you go like man,
like talk about being like sucked into
the plot.
Like you're,
it's all you're on is
people who are lying in conspiring to
make money or kill half the population
or whatever the fuck it is they're
doing.
What are you sure this is it an
attractive thought pattern.
That's the problem.
When these God conspiracies,
they're attractive thought pro patterns
that mimic like real problem solving
that could benefit you in real life.
So instead of like actually paying
attention to your real life,
you get sucked into this idea of you
being the one who's going to figure out
who killed JFK and you ride that fucking
thing 12 hours a day all day long and in
the and then after a while like are you
a researcher or you just a dude has gone
crazy paying attention to the JFK
assassination.
Like which,
which one are you?
You've got to be careful because this,
this feeling that you get when you chase
down secrets and conspiracies,
the government deal,
Illuminati,
we're going to expose this man.
It's,
it's,
it gives extra and exaggerated meaning
to your time and anything that gives
extra and exaggerated meaning to your
time should be closely considered as to
whether or not it's beneficial.
Like if something gives you extra and
exaggerated feelings,
you got to go well is this love?
Is this a hot girl?
I like the fuck.
Is it a a fun sport that I picked up the
now I'm addicted to like what is it any,
how much of this is good and how much of
this is chem trails?
You know,
how much of this is just you just
spending a lot of time on something that
turns out to be total nonsense.
How much?
I like micro conspiracies way better.
Like little things like you know like
the,
like if you could add a value meal at
Mcdonald's,
it's a more expensive than if you buy
all three things separately and stuff
like that.
That's true.
That's true too.
If you get a value meal at Mcdonald's,
you can add more expensive than if you
put all the things together.
Really?
Yeah.
But those kinds of conspiracies you just
broke that broke that story.
I'm,
it's going to be giant.
Does kind of conspiracies to are to me
are way funding it because you can prove
it easier.
Right,
but that's not a conspiracy.
Conspiracy's like doing it.
What?
Why are they doing that?
Do they know about it?
Oh,
there must be some incentive to get
people when you get it as a package,
you would,
what I would say is if there's a meal
package that's less money,
it might still be more money than they
would have spent if they didn't go for
the meal package.
So they might only get one thing.
They might only get a burger and maybe
only get a drink.
But if you offer some things in a
package of times,
people are going to gravitate towards
that packet.
You right.
You're saying that it's a way to upsell.
Yeah.
So,
even though it might cost less to buy it
as a package,
they still might be spending more than
they would a split if they didn't buy
the package because they might've just
got a cheeseburger by itself.
Oh,
that's totally legit.
Yeah.
And it's 41 600
marketing x was awesome.
And they add the 41 sentence that's like
buying the extended warranty.
I don't think you need that.
Mcdonald's sued because extra value
meals,
41 cents more.
Wow.
I wonder how much I'm going to spend on
legal fees and that conundrum.
How could you get sued for that?
You didn't mean unless you said,
I mean the fucking price is on the wall.
You dumb cunt.
Cause it's called extra value meal
meaning values.
It's like kind of false advertising.
A little,
I guess.
Is it?
I guess frog,
he's just a lawsuit.
The lawsuit filled this month was a file
this month was about principle,
not 41 cents.
He seeks a class action status for
consumer fraud and deceptive practices.
Lawsuit Against Mcdonald's operator
Charisse management.
Huh?
I love that Mcdonald's exists,
but it should be illegal.
Why?
It's fucking barely food,
man.
I had it the other day.
Okay,
that's fucking great.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I know two men.
Every now and then I'll stop on the way
home and get a filet of fish.
Oh,
the fries.
See,
I don't fuck with fries.
Not that much.
A little bit here and there,
but they don't get me those filet a fish
has get me the fish fresh.
You have to have a fresh one.
But I made the mistake before eight,
the last one watching a fucking
documentary on how they prepare those,
those fish cakes that you buy,
that fucking Jesus Christ.
It's the other.
They treat all the fish with chemicals.
They remove all the smell.
That's why when you eat like filet of
fish,
they never fucking smell.
They don't smell right.
You ever have dude,
I hate you ever catch a fish and cook it
like later in the day.
But if you wait too long,
it starts to stink.
You know?
Especially if it's in the sun.
Like you gotta be careful with fish
fishes awake way different than any
other like food in that.
The closest proximity you have to that
thing being caught and then killed and
then you eat it.
The closer those are together,
it makes us a giant impact on the way it
felt.
It tastes.
So they figured out some weird way to
treat all this stuff that was watching
them do it there.
They kill so many fish do.
It's crazy.
If you watch like one of them filet a
fish factory places and you see the fish
is being poured in,
you just want to go stop,
stop,
stop.
It
zig a mass murder.
You can't take any more fish.
There's not going to be any more fish.
Oh my God.
What are they doing?
That's hilarious dude.
It's crazy.
They just have trucks.
They're backing it up.
Dumping gigantic piles of fish in there.
Well think about chickens man.
You,
you got a Boston market.
I've just got a half a chicken,
you know,
and that.
Yeah,
and that's a half of life.
I just ate and it was alive probably
once a month ago.
Yeah.
That's so much chicken.
So much chicken.
It doesn't make the people were there
before you relation theory thing makes
more sense.
Cause there's no way there was that much
chicken,
you know,
here's,
here's what's
going on.
Where we,
we have decided that we operate better
and calmer and gigantic groups.
And even though like there's more
stress,
I mean by better and calmer,
like as a civilization,
like there's more bp punk,
honk fuck you,
maybe more murder or maybe more crime
because everybody's jammed on top of
each other.
So you're going to have a bunch of like
errant behavior no matter what you do.
But the only way we can do that as if we
are not involved at all in the
production of food.
So the production of food is kind of
taken away from people because we all
together,
if we lived in a neighborhood,
right?
Say if I lived near you and you know,
Joey's up the street and you know,
burt's up the street and we all decide
with,
it's like a,
uh,
you know,
like a co op and we're going to grow our
own food.
I mean that's,
people have done that before.
Hippies do that shit all the time.
They love to do it.
Um,
if we had them all stacked on top of
each other and fucked up like that,
we'd be like,
hey guys,
what are we doing?
Like this is fucked up.
Like these chickens aren't even,
they're not even,
they're never a lot.
They just were just treating them like
shit until we kill him.
Like that seems kind of fucked up,
right?
I guarantee you we'd all agree.
We don't be like,
yeah,
all right,
how do we do this better?
You know,
what do we need more space?
We need to treat it more humanely.
They needed an omnivorous diet.
They need to be able to free range and
roam around and be like a real chicken
until the end comes.
So it's not like a life of torture and
then death.
It's just life and death.
So you'll eliminate by using your
intellect,
you eliminate that torture.
But the thing is,
we don't encounter it,
man.
You know?
Have you ever been to a slaughterhouse?
No.
I W deaf.
Um,
maybe I have maybe a cow.
No,
no,
I haven't.
No.
I,
I went to a place where they milk cow a
farm.
But
yeah,
that's even rough man.
Those cows jammed up against those metal
bars and then they're uh,
they're yanking on their tits like,
oh yeah,
this is a,
it's all weird,
man.
It's all weird because we don't see it.
Like we just go get milk.
That's the fucked up part.
We've created these systems and go get
milk is not nearly as fucking weird is
go get a cheeseburger at Mcdonald's,
cause go get a cheeseburger.
It's like they've done all the work.
They grew the cow that killed the cow.
They chopped it up,
they grounded up,
they cooked it,
they put it on a bun,
they wrapped that Bun and paper that
gave it to you and it took a couple of
seconds.
I mean,
you can go to a Mcdonald's right now.
You pull up that drive through,
get a juicy as quarter pounder with
cheese.
Ooh.
And it'll be in your fat fucking greasy
mouth and three minutes.
That's amazing.
Is the only way that can happen is if
you're not involved in the process is
the only way it can happen.
Like we kind of kill a lot of fucking
cows to do that.
You can't,
we can't all be like everybody who eats
cow be out there killing cows.
We wouldn't get shit done.
There would be no insurance companies.
There would be no video games that ever
get developed.
We wouldn't have time.
We'd be out there fucking mowing fields
and shit.
We'd be out there shooting cows in the
head and hanging them up by their
ankles,
fake foods on the way very soon I think.
I mean,
especially since recently they've
had a lot of good breakthroughs from
like growing food,
you know?
Yeah.
That's 100% gonna happen.
And once that happens,
it's going to be interesting to see if
they just like have like one year of
like last year to have real counts,
slaughter them all and just keep like
one cow per county or something.
They're doing this style.
Like,
you know how Peter Kills a lot of cats
and dogs?
I tell people that and they go,
what?
Yeah,
Peta euthanizes a lot of cats and dogs.
Unfortunately they say they don't have
the money to keep them alive.
Just hi irony in a,
in a way that the,
is that the ethical treatment of animals
that kill him,
like,
like there's no way,
like they're,
they have no kill animal shelters in la
where they don't kill the animals,
take them in,
they try to find them a home like
squeaky member.
My Docs Wiki,
she was in there for like six months or
something crazy and callen founder and
then I adopted her.
But um,
yeah,
I don't know ma'am.
I think our relationship to life itself,
going back to what you were asking me
about the forest,
our relationship to life itself is very
disjointed.
I think.
Um,
we were raised by people who were
brainwashed by the 1960s [inaudible]
1970s media and movies and TV shows and
whatever they learned from their
parents.
You got to think of who their parents
were.
Their parents were fucking immigrants.
Man.
I mean,
my grandparents came straight from the
boat,
all of them,
all of them.
My,
my mom's side,
all of them.
On my father's side,
my father's side,
half from Ireland,
the grandfather was from Ireland,
grandmother was from Italy,
everybody else,
Italy,
they all came over here on a boat.
They all just took a fucking Jan's it.
They didn't know shit dude.
And there's no way they would have
prepared you for the Internet.
They just didn't know.
So it's like with every passing
generation will become more and more
aware of how weird this thing is,
which is why he can't have a movie with
Robert Deniro was sucking on Juliette
Lewis,
you know,
tits.
He can't do that today,
right?
I don't think so.
No.
Back then you could do it because they
didn't know any better.
I mean literally didn't know any better.
You know,
like when people talk about like Roman
Polanski,
mom Rome,
clamp clamp,
see what he did.
He had sex with a 13 year old girl and
he drugged her and all that said
there's,
there's never an excuse for that.
Right.
He's a piece of shit for sure for doing
that.
Right.
But that when during that time,
like way back then,
I bet.
I bet that was way more common than we
would like
Marlin Brando.
Yeah,
that's shit that just recently came out.
How that was supposedly a real rape
scene in that movie.
Last tango of something.
I Dunno right now will was that girl?
Uh,
I don't know.
She was like 17 or 18.
Like she wasn't told that she was going
to do that.
They just did it to her.
Yeah.
Twat the fuck man.
It's a different world back then.
Oh well we,
we've talked about this a couple of
times about how go to those 1950s
movies.
Men always hit women.
The fucking hit them all the time.
Sean connery,
you remember that interview?
He did.
Yeah.
That's one of my favorite interviews
ever.
We played that recent.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
With Barbara Walters,
if you haven't heard it folks,
you should go listen to it on youtube
cause it's Barbara Walters.
She thinks she has him.
That's one of the,
one of the interesting things about it
is that she brings up that he has said
that sometimes it's okay to hit a woman
and she sticks it to him like,
you know,
get out of this one.
And he says,
well,
I believe sometimes it's good to hit
one.
They just push it and push it and they
don't know when to let it go.
And then some time shafter use the back
of your hand.
And he did.
And you can see the har it Barbara
Walters phase,
last tango in Paris.
Brando was 48 and she was 19 wow.
And so they did that to her without her
having any idea that she was going to do
it.
That that was the scene.
Yeah.
Man,
they didn't have her consent.
It wasn't,
or something like that that he didn't
regret filming the scene without
Schneider's consent,
but admitted to feeling guilty.
Huh?
Wow.
48 Brando.
She was 19 that's great.
Brenda was a free car.
What a strange guy.
Company got giant.
He just got enormous and apparently that
was why they filmed them in apocalypse
now.
Like the oldest film them in the dark.
So big.
Yeah,
just crazy fucker.
You know,
when you think about trying to figure
out what life is about,
like now as an adult,
we're,
we're the poor fools that will be looked
upon by our grandchildren.
Like fools.
Like when,
when our grandchildren are our age and
they talk about,
you know,
how fucking goofy our world was that we
live in now.
No wonder why we elected trump.
No wonder why we still have this
ridiculous electoral college system and
we still have representative democracy.
You still can't vote online.
The wonder why pot is still illegal in
most of the country.
No wonder why private prisons are filled
with people in jail for ridiculous shit
and people are profiting off it.
No wonder why they didn't get it yet.
They were so close.
We're just like,
we're looking back on like the people
that own slaves and were going,
how did they do that?
How could that ever happen?
How could the United States have been
founded by slave labor?
How could these people have brought
these people from Africa?
How could they have beaten them and
tortured them and cut their feet off if
they didn't,
if they tried to flee,
but they did.
And this is going to be the same thing
people say of us when they look back on
us,
they got to go,
oh my God,
they were,
they didn't.
They had to kill animals to get meat.
Dude,
they didn't even get meat from the meat
science.
There's no meat science.
They didn't have a meat science company.
They just got,
they had a shoot.
Things with sticks.
They haven't figured out Asians were
robots yet.
I think there are aliens that microphone
is on.
My girlfriend doesn't have a,
uh,
you know,
where you pound on the knee and it
reflects reflex like three people.
I've tried it on her knees when she's
around you.
She's numb.
But three people have tried.
But my thought was
there's like,
I feel like if you had to pick one,
eh,
one ethnicity that excels in like
science and mathematics,
I always go with Asian.
I just always feel like they,
and that is that racist in a positive
way.
Because if it is,
I'm positively racist towards agents.
I just think they have,
there's a great deal of them that are
really good at science and mathematics
and if they're,
if they're aliens,
they probably just crashed here cause
they were driving their ufo.
My thought was that when the Annunaki
came down here and they kidnapped the
monkeys and they turned them into
people,
they had probably like varying doses,
you know,
like my people didn't get,
like the Italians didn't get a very good
dose of alien.
It's like mostly monkey,
some alien either just use one kind of
monkey.
It's multiple kinds of monkeys.
May Be.
It's possible to also,
where were all the hominids?
Were they all in one little forest,
the ones that became people or was it,
was there similar things happening in
several spots all throughout the world?
Like a lot of other animals,
like birds.
I think I'm on many different birds.
There are the different birds all over
the fucking planet.
Right.
Why would we,
why would we assume that the only places
that we didn't make any sense,
we actually kind of know where the
monkeys were from.
Yeah.
The uncontacted Amazon tribe.
This is really recent.
They had these pictures of these people,
these fucking people man are living
right now.
Like it just,
there's something fucked up about going
in there and taking pictures.
It's really,
I get that everybody wants to see it,
but it's,
you're going to ruin this.
Like this is incredible and I know it's
important.
It's a total catch 22 cause I know it's
important to document.
It's very important document,
but it's also,
this is an amazing thing that exists
right now.
You could peer into the past.
These people are literally live in,
that guy has a homemade bow and arrow
and you can see as cac,
he's got a little arrows strapped to his
hip.
He's got a leaf over his dick and that
guy's pointing at bow and Arrow at this
drone or whatever the hell it is is
taking these photos.
I don't know what they smell like,
dude,
they don't know what's going on and
they're freaking out.
This is crazy.
Like look at that.
Look on that guy's face.
He doesn't even know what he's seeing.
This an uncontacted tribe man,
like as they go deeper and deeper into
the Amazon,
they find pockets of prehistoric people.
They don't have any,
they don't have any contact with the
outside world.
They're not wearing tee shirts.
They're not wearing adidas.
They don't have any plastic.
These fucking people are living just
like people lived 30,000
years ago there.
That's amazing.
She knows man,
to be able to,
this is such a rare moment.
If they could figure out a way to visit
these people,
like have them except you.
You would have to actually be one of
them to really find out what their like
like unaffected.
You would almost have to be one of them.
Well,
you'd have to do is you'd have to take
one of them,
kidnap them,
copy their brain onto a robot that
looked like them.
Send that robot in to talk to the
picnics to the
what if he just came in there with like
a bunch of dead meat though.
Like here,
like just holding up,
meet,
walking slowly going,
hey,
and you're putting it down.
Then they might give me,
he's giving us,
see the thing about these hunter
gatherer tribes like this is they need
to get food every day.
Like if you give the meat,
they'll be super happy.
But it's not like if I gave you a side
of beef,
he'd be like,
wow,
I'll put this in the freezer like this.
That meat is not going to last like no
matter what,
it's just not going to,
they're in the jungle.
It gets funky in an hour.
Punch of twinkies.
Then they got a hunt everyday dude,
my friend Steve Rinella went to this uh,
place in,
um,
fuck was it bornea Bolivia.
He went to Bolivia and he hung out with
these,
uh,
tribal people in Bolivia,
in the woods with them,
said it was nuts.
They don't wear shoes there.
Their feet are like thick with calluses
and they're,
they're splayed out,
their toes are splayed out.
It's like you're,
their feet don't look anything like ours
because they never wear shoes.
And they gave these guys some shoes
like,
hey,
you know,
as a gift.
And they put them on and you're like,
what the fuck is this?
They didn't want them like their feet
have gotten so calloused dcs.
They don't have to use these.
Probably don't have anything.
Sorry,
Jamie didn't make any sense.
They gave in one of them.
Right,
but they gave these people boots,
Brian,
that you would wear if you lived in the
jungle.
They didn't want to have nothing to do
with it.
I guess if you just walk around all the
time,
your feet would get so hard that you
could walk on anything.
Yeah.
Have you seen that guy's feet that like
walked across the country?
Which country?
This country really barefoot.
Yeah.
America is doing it right now actually,
I think for the three barefoot.
Yeah.
It sounds like a bad idea.
Well,
there was that one guy that was on that
dual survival show and that was his
shtick was that he walks barefoot
everywhere.
You never knew him,
man.
When the shoe store is going to run off.
She was imagine though,
if you live your whole life like an
asshole walking outside barefoot and
then the day you die you're like,
God dammit.
They still have shoes and then two and
then ends.
Are you mostly barefoot around your
house?
Yeah,
I'm barefoot all the time.
What does that,
that's his feet.
Yeah,
my feet.
That doesn't look that bad.
Yeah,
it looks like that's a woman dude.
Oh God.
This is your personal collection.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
That's
his name.
Yeah.
I said mark bombers.
Why does that look like a woman in that
photo along here?
I don't know.
Oh,
is that a hippie thing?
Yeah.
Did I just do,
I do what grandpa does.
46th day of walking barefoot.
It's my 46 days though.
Oh,
that's when they just started out doing
it.
It's not,
he hasn't been doing it for years or
anything.
I would imagine more cuts and stuff.
It doesn't seem like a good idea.
Well,
it seems like you definitely would get
some infections and shit in the
beginning,
which seems like mental illness with the
guy has.
I think it's one of those things where
you just gotta do it over and over and
over again.
I'd do it slowly and then have it built
up to go to see if you find that dual
survivor his feet,
because he,
he used to walk on the show everywhere
in the jungle,
stepping on twigs and shit barefoot.
His feet were way more discussing that
guys,
his feet will like Werewolf feet.
They just look cool.
But if you want to,
you know,
if you want to just have tough feet,
I think of that Jesus had a fucked up
foot.
That's the dual survivor guy.
Yeah.
His ridiculous feat,
Dude.
Everywhere he goes,
he walks.
Look at that barefoot.
Disgusting.
Imagine paying someone to suck your toes
and they look like that.
You don't have to be a real piece of
shit.
Wow.
You wouldn't even feel it.
You might as well be sucking on the
bottom of a table,
you know?
You don't feel that like those,
those things are numb.
I would imagine.
The only good thing about having cow's
feet though.
It's like when you start stepping on
things that would normally hurt you,
you won't feel it.
So it's kind of like making your own
shoe out of,
you're on foot with,
but that's just the bottom of the hill
that looks infected and that looks like
the homeless guy by my house with
gangrene.
What does named Cody London.
That's his name.
Shout out to cody.
It's not,
that's an interesting world man.
That world of people that are preppers
and survivalists and they want to stay
alive.
And I had another conversation with less
trout the other day.
He came to the comedy store.
He's doubling down on big foot.
Let me see the socks.
I wish,
I wish he uh,
I wish you found them.
I would fucking love it.
I'll be so happy if less trout found big
foot.
He's fuck.
He goes looking for it all the time.
Seriously.
What if there's like five of them?
There's only five of them.
Even talking about it as if there might
be a possibility.
Journeys you're angry.
Meanwhile you,
you have no problem with a lot of other
ridiculous fantasies like movies and
video games and all kinds of fancy
stuff.
Right?
You have no problem with rogue one boot
one haven't seen.
Have you seen it to know it hurts code
here.
It's very good.
I liked the last one.
So young.
Jamie says as much better than the last
one.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
I mean,
I enjoyed it more cooler,
but I don't know what the fuck's going
on though is that's part of the problem.
It's like when does it happening?
It's a prelude to which one?
The original what?
Hold on.
So this is just before,
okay,
so the last one was way after the first
one,
but this new one is going to way be way
before the first one.
The last,
the last one you saw?
Yes.
Yeah,
I think so.
That's way after darth vader when get
out last year.
This is the first one.
Spoiler alert.
I mean,
Han Solo was older,
obviously this is like after the first
one,
right?
But now this one's going to go before
the original one that introduced Han
Solo.
But you're never going to get a fucking
Han solo guy again.
I feel like like that the age of that
kind of actor is pretty much over the
age of like the superstar movie,
like iconic Han Solo type characters.
I was thinking about that recently.
I think the problem is that it's because
those guys are still here doing those
movies.
Bruce Willis,
Tom Cruise,
Harrison Ford's still making movies,
but doe many outs.
I mean they did.
It doesn't seem like any new guys are
doing that.
See the new blade runners is a new blade
runner.
Oh God.
And Harrison Ford's in it.
And uh,
what's his face?
Mark or Ryan Gosling.
Yeah.
Ryan gosling.
Ooh.
But what about the other guy?
Um,
who was the,
the main robot guy?
Fuck robot guy.
Yeah.
The guy who was,
um,
his main enemy at the end of the first
movie.
Oh,
rutger.
Hauer.
Yeah.
Remember that guy?
That guy was the shit.
This is the preview watching him right
now.
The new one.
Pull this audio.
Okay.
Yeah.
Pull the audio narration going on right
now with Harrison Ford.
And uh,
I see.
It's weird.
When you redo something,
man,
you had redoing it.
It seems like they're doing it right
cause they kept the narrative is a real
feel of the film and there this looks
dope and it's by really Scott again.
So,
oh,
powerful.
Really.
Scott Alien snakes walking up to some
like ship.
It looks up.
Oh yeah.
Maybe this is not the best thing for
people to have on Youtube.
Okay.
All right.
Let's just,
we'll see it later.
I'll show up.
We'll see it later.
Oh this isn't even the one I saw.
It was a different one.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Brian,
this is happening in real time.
Oh wait,
no,
this is all right.
Yeah.
And then which Ryan,
is that awesome?
Okay,
I'm confused.
I saw him the other day at,
this is the Reynolds and the gospel by
Harrison Ford with a gun.
It looks all shaky.
I might rush them.
So great blade runner.
Wow,
that'd be bad ass.
I hope they do it well.
I just,
I think we need more science fiction
movies that are really good and we need
more horror movies that are really good.
Just not enough.
Not in a fucking monster movies anymore.
Just stop making them black mirrors that
my latest new horror.
Maybe I should just fucking creepy as
fuck.
That's a crazy,
crazy show.
One of my favorite shows of time.
Why
is it a monster movie?
Well,
well,
one of the episodes each episode's
really fucked up,
but one episodes scare like,
like he's in a haunted house and it's
mixing virtual reality with simulation.
Oiler alert.
Spoiler alert.
Floody farther.
It's crazy though.
Um,
we,
I got so high.
Yes,
they would run away.
I started believing in ghosts.
Ron White was telling me he lived in a
haunted house and I was like,
wow.
You sure?
Wow.
Used to live in a haunted house.
Your shorts haunted.
I was looking at those rules up on real
estate.
There is something,
they've been in California,
you have to disclose if someone died in
your house.
If you're trying to sell it within three
years or something like that,
she'd be a lot more than that.
That's for a lot less than that.
Rather.
That's for smell reasons though or
something.
That's for health code reasons.
Her,
I dunno.
Not less than that.
I meant more than that in the first
place.
Um,
that was,
uh,
I was going to bring up a story about,
um,
the girl who died in boulder.
What's the little girl's name?
That benet Ramsey.
Ramsey.
Yeah.
That house,
they can't sell the fucking house.
They can't sell.
They've changed the name of the street.
They can't sell that house.
How much is it?
It changed your address.
You don't want to do this.
It's expensive house.
Very nice house.
It's in boulder,
like in boulder proper,
which is like very expensive.
They sold it.
Yeah.
Houses.
When does this,
this year.
Wow.
That house has been for sale for,
I'm not exaggerating.
Maybe like nine years.
10 years.
Damn.
Yeah,
and I think some people bought it and
they redid it and they tried to change
the name of it.
That's who this is.
They own the house.
The people that bought it right after
the randy's moved out in 2004,
I guess,
had been trying to sell it for 10 years.
Yeah.
So they just sold it and some new people
bought it.
Man,
if it is haunted,
I don't think there's a um,
expiration date on ghost.
Dude Watch.
They were having trouble selling it.
Oh,
so they haven't sold it yet.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's the case.
So that was the point is that these
people bought this house,
they fixed it up and they're like,
well,
it's beautiful house.
It'll sell.
Nobody wants it.
I started watching it go show recently
and that's like,
I think you've talked about it many
times,
but I've never seen it before that ghost
hunters or what a,
what a ridiculous fake show that is.
There's a bunch of them.
We know which one you saw,
but there's like four or five different
of those.
Ghost shows.
The one that's and true tv w but they
actually edit in like kids laughing and
stuff and they're like,
do your that.
I swear it sounds like kids laughing and
it's just like a stock audio of like,
you know,
like it's so bad.
Yeah.
They don't have any obligation to tell
the truth by the way.
Sorry if you're so fucking stupid.
You really believe that the guys on
those ghost hunter shows are gonna
expose the truth in the next commercial
break.
You know,
like the next commercial break and wait,
what was that?
Oh my God.
Coming up next.
Oh,
he's not real
show that people,
I think it was called fear on MTV with
it.
I got a go pro on someone's face,
like go sit in this dark room for two
hours and if you can think he went money
or some shit like theirs to try to
freak.
I,
they were trying to freak them out,
but they tried to make it seem like we
are in haunted houses and different
prisons and shit like that.
Hmm.
That's awful.
Yeah.
Boy,
we love watching other people freak out.
It's like horror movies,
man.
Like there's,
what is it about a horror movie?
I remember that scene from American
Werewolf in London where there was a
businessman on the subway in London and
he's walking along and he looks behind
him and he sees the wolf and you know
that he sees the wolf and he starts
running and you,
you barely see the wolf,
you see the wolf for like maybe a half,
a second like maybe and then he's
running and he keeps looking back and
he's terrified and he fucking runs up
this escalator and he trips and falls
and his briefcase falls apart and he's
trying to pick up the stop and he looks
down at the bottom of the escalator and
for like a split second you see the
Werewolf and it makes you shit your
fucking pants.
Cause you think about like one of you
were that guy and this thing is running
through the airport chasing you and then
you just can't keep it together anymore.
You're out of shape.
You get to the top of that escalator,
you fall down,
you collapse.
He looked down and you're like,
oh my God,
it's,
they're like,
we love that shit.
People love being freaked out.
Watch it.
Some poor bastard about to get jacked.
It stresses me out.
You don't like those movies?
I mean,
no,
I don't like being stressed out.
That's why I couldn't,
I never finished breaking bad.
I've watched the first episode and I was
like,
yeah,
I get it.
That's,
that was stressful.
I don't need to do any more.
That gave up on the walking dead.
Really?
I heard it's just turned a corner now.
It was way too torturey.
I was like,
this is a torture show.
It's like all of a sudden the,
the zombies are pussies.
Like all of a sudden the zombies aren't
any threat at all.
It's just the people.
She finished the zombies coming here.
You just fucking pushed him to the side.
Get out of here.
These zombies used to be able to tear
open a horse.
They used to take down a fucking full
grown horse or rip it apart and eat it
alive.
Do you know how quick a fucking horse
would run over 30 40 people,
like a 30 40 people.
Just regular strength.
People went and had a horse cornered in
a stable and tried to eat the horse
while it's alive.
That horse would kick the fuck out of
you.
Everybody would go flying.
You would take maybe 15 seconds and we'd
all be dead.
The horse would just kick you and kick
you.
You would never bite through his fucking
skin and eat him.
But in this stupid show,
at one point in time,
the zombies could just tear open a
horse.
So what are they?
Are they super powerful or are they
pussies?
They walk like two miles an hour or that
could they corner a fucking giant horse?
Tell me what's going on here.
What if one?
What if it's just like if the person was
super strong before they came,
became a Zombie.
It doesn't work on the horse.
Even a bunch of strong men get 50 strong
men to try to take out a horse.
That guy's going to get kicked.
This is not,
I don't want to see this,
Jamie.
Don't let me see this.
Oh son,
you got to Kod.
I got,
I got k the fuck.
Oh God.
You got a whole sequence of them,
like a collaboration.
I do not want to watch a play in the PAC
dudes getting checked by horses.
But let me tell you something.
You could have a hundred people tried to
corral horse and rip it apart.
That horse will send people fucking
flying.
It's like,
look,
if I was in a room with a hundred
Chihuahuas,
it we're trying to kill me.
Guess who's getting out of the room?
Me,
you're going to be a hundred dead
fucking two hours and me.
You know why?
Cause I'm a person and I'm bigger than a
goddamned Chihuahua.
That's like a better I have.
I have less good odds than a hundred
people trying to eat a horse.
Oh,
horses will kick the fuck out of you
unless you have a gun or a spear or
something.
You're going to have to penetrate that
things.
Vital organs.
He's going to beat the fuck out of
everybody.
You can't just eat the horse.
Yeah,
fuck Outta here.
Your rules don't fit.
They did that.
You're like,
you're,
you haven't made a coherent universe
where things are consistent.
Like sometimes these zombies can tear
through things and eat a living horse
and sometimes he's fucking things.
You just push him to the side.
They can't even bite you.
Like they're not as frantic.
They move slower.
They're not a consideration.
This word we're doing,
we're breaking down the zombies and
Zombie psychology here,
uh,
at all.
Things considered.
Please consider donating because what
would we have put together here?
It's all put together by your generous
contributions coming up next.
Zombie physics,
bite physics,
how they bite through things.
How do you buy?
All you need is like a thick jacket and
just stab them on the head here.
Pipe my arm.
Stupid.
Stabbing the fucking head there.
It's super power.
Strength.
Yeah.
Sometimes.
Sometimes like the first episode of the
new season,
Rick's just shucking them to the side.
Like he's some goddamn super linemen.
They're a bunch of high school players.
He's just chucking them,
moving them around like they're nothing.
Nobody bites him.
30 40 of them at a time.
Not one of them gets a hold of them,
bites him.
Fuck you.
It should be somebody's job to be like,
make sure that is a thing.
You know where the wood,
yeah.
Consistent.
They can't do that with a storyline
because the storyline is too weird,
man.
The storyline is like now you know
everybody,
the zombies are still around but the
people become a problem.
The zombies are still around but they
don't eat and it's been years and uh,
I guess they're just around.
And a unlike anything we've ever
observed,
they don't deteriorate and fall away
from not eating.
Like what the fuck are these stupid slow
comments going to feed themselves every
day?
Did they have a digestive system?
They can just write into this story
like,
oh,
we figured it out.
Why some are stronger than the others.
So some have eaten,
they hate
that.
Sounds like an ABC after school.
Special finish.
Westworld.
Yes.
That's a good show.
I fucking love that.
That's great show.
That's a show that has so much weird
room to move around cause they jumped
timelines and you,
you never know who's a robot and who's
not
a robot and it's just getting slippery
or and slippery or,
and it's Anthony fucking hopkins and,
and the other guy,
ed,
uh,
Harris and Harris both,
I mean top flight actors and then that
girl who plays Delores,
what is her name?
God Damn,
she's good.
She scares the shit out of me.
Like a girl,
like that is the type of girl that could
just act like that and like get you to
fall in love with her.
Like if a girl can act that good and a
movie,
like if she wanted to use it for evil,
she could.
I feel like if data,
if you have these local girls,
these actresses,
Rachel Wood,
it's not fair.
If you can do that,
they can use it for evil.
Yeah,
they can date you pretty like hide the
crazy way easier because they can just
act like they're nice and normal.
Well also most people who are crazy
don't even know that they're crazy.
It's not like you're going,
I know I'm crazy,
but I can't let Brian know I'm crazy.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
pretend even with facebook though,
and everyone calling them crazy for like
a couple of years,
and then they got to figure it out.
Ego.
First of all,
those people on facebook,
I ain't paying him no mind cause I ain't
about haters.
I ain't about haters.
Preach seat.
I think there's a way that we can all
justify who we are and how we are.
And I don't think crazy people have some
sort of clarity that we don't possess.
I think that's ridiculous.
I think it's probably quite the
opposite.
I bet they have way less clarity.
They have no idea.
They're crazy.
They think the world sucks.
World's full of retards.
Justin bieber went to bed and probably
got up that morning,
man,
what a bunch of retards we met last
night.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
the fucking redband retard oh garden,
you know,
like he probably has no idea how he came
off.
It's,
that's uh,
that's,
that's way more common than not.
So these real dummies,
it's crazy people,
these nutty people,
they probably didn't even know that that
nunny they think they're a little nutty
sometimes.
What's the big deal?
God,
you know?
Yeah,
I have video of him saying,
uh,
uh yeah,
but have you ever slept with 20
supermodels to this black guy?
And when the black guy came up,
he goes,
what's up man?
And word like he said,
no,
no to this black guy.
He like,
he yelled something to this black guy,
said this black guy comes up and puts
down his food and he goes,
what's up?
Mind inward.
And I was like,
I'm scared of saying that word.
It's weird.
I don't like saying it man.
Because then nowadays people make it
bring tones and shit.
Well it's a fucking problem.
Magic words are never good folks.
It's not good.
It's not good because it makes them more
valuable when you say it now it has,
it holds more power becomes a more
loaded word that lenny bruce argued
about that and like 1950s he,
it was one of his bits.
It was like one of his most
controversial bits.
You would point people out in the
audience and call there's a nigger,
there's a SPEC share the kike.
Yeah,
yeah dude.
It was a crazy,
crazy bit.
And at the
time like people had no idea where he
was going with it because nobody had
ever done that kind of comedy before.
But he was essentially saying that if
you,
the more you use those words,
the more they lose their power and the
more they'll never have the ability to
hurt some child's feelings.
And it was pretty profound,
especially considering that he had,
you know,
had to realize like what happens when
he's censor things and censor people and
ain't figured that out in the 1960
somehow,
you know,
he figured out like this is,
this is cakes counterproductive.
Like you can't,
you can't demonize a word where it's
just conveying tent like we were talking
about earlier.
Like the hardest thing in the world is
to convey your thoughts through your
words and to make certain words
supercharged and decide.
Certain words have like magic fucking
powers in the game and they can jump
three steps.
No,
no,
they're just fucking words matter.
And words are supposed to be flexible
and they're supposed to all contribute
to the best possible job you can do of
conveying your intent.
And as soon as you have like
supercharged war z you can't use
anymore.
Well then I can't,
it's,
I have less tools to convey my intent.
I have less.
You have less of an ability to
understand what I'm saying.
And you're,
you're assuming that the exact same word
from one sentence to the next as the
same con is the same content as the same
ability?
The same.
It means the same thing cause it doesn't
always mean the same thing.
You know like someone can call you a
bitch and if it's your friend,
it's funny like if you,
if Dunkin comes over and like what's up
bitch and and like goes to grab your
take or something.
Like it'd be hilarious,
right?
Cause he's Dunkin cause it's your
friend.
Whereas if Justin Bieber says it to you
in your,
you know,
in line,
in front of,
I'm a big boy,
you wouldn't,
you know,
this doesn't feel good.
Or if some guy says that to you,
some guy comes up to you like,
what's up bitch?
And you're like,
oh,
well this doesn't feel good.
It just feels terrible.
Right?
It's cause the intense different,
it's,
you know,
it's different.
The word doesn't always mean the same
thing.
A word just conveys intent and it's not
that fucking good me and we're really
good at it compared to animals,
but we're not that good at it then then
that an in that,
not that good at it.
That's why songs are cool.
You know,
like you could repeat the same shit over
and over and over again anywhere else.
That's annoying,
you know?
Ah,
well I don't fuck Whoa,
ah,
and potty you ever Bj,
you got a whole crowd repeating the same
shit over and over and over again
because we've decided that the,
those noises,
those words,
they convey an intent that we can all
support and the music backs it up.
Right.
You're not a big kiss fan.
You don't know.
I don't understand.
Yeah.
So what I'm saying,
you were denied that your youth should
play kiss miniature golf in Vegas next
time you go.
That's pretty fun.
How about no,
what,
what's to Hannah Walls that sing?
Uh,
birds,
monkeys,
monkeys saying they make crazy sounds
right,
but is that a call or a song?
Um,
well,
none of them are songs.
I think birds are songs.
Maybe they're beautiful.
But what about like whales?
We all sing.
That's a humming,
like what is the,
okay,
like do you think you know for sure what
a whale sounds like when it's like whale
sounds?
Do you know just the,
the audio that didn't hear the audio of
weight?
Let's heal whale songs.
Yeah.
It's like that.
Riley a dolphins.
It's like,
alright,
so we know that [inaudible] humpback
whales.
Okay,
here we go.
Whoa.
Oh,
speaking of which,
have you done the htc vive yet?
The Osha.
Oh No,
I signed up playstation.
Ocean.
Hello.
Okay.
Wow.
It's just repeating it over and that's
it.
That's amazing.
That sounds incredible.
Wow.
I ducked just dat.
Sound alone.
Just completely changed the way I think
about Wales.
Does that sound like crying to you or
no?
Positive or negative?
They're communicating didn't sound
negative sounding like they're
communicating,
but it makes you realize how fucking
smart they are.
I don't know what they're saying,
but I can tell that that's a language.
There were,
there were repeating certain sounds and
doing it in a way that's,
it's like it's clear the differences in
the sounds.
It sounds like a fucking language man.
Yes.
And also you got to think like what up
when you,
when you stop and think about how we've
all chosen certain languages,
whether it's Chinese or Spanish or
whatever,
you know,
the region that we are,
the world that we live in,
we've chosen certain languages that
become like our standard way of making
sounds that convey our ideas.
But these things have,
they've gone a totally different path,
but it's Kinda the same thing.
They're like those Amazon tribes,
people that they discovered,
you know,
their people,
their brains are probably just like our
brains exactly the same,
but they never encountered all these
metals,
plastics and
all the innovations that came with the,
um,
industrial era.
So they just live like people have
thousands and thousands of years ago,
but there's the same.
It's the same thing,
right?
They're just people.
They probably have some crazy language
that we don't know,
but go down there and try to figure it.
You'll hear them talking and be like,
what in the fuck are they saying?
Like what is this?
Like what kind of language is this?
That's what it was going on with that
Dolphin.
I was listening to that think talk and I
was like,
oh my God,
they can't kill these.
How are they killing these?
They've got to stop killing me.
Like whoever it is with this,
I know a sea shepherd bus,
a lot of people all the time sea
shepherd,
they catch these people cause there's,
there's an embargo or not an embargo.
It's,
it's,
it's illegal in most places to kill
whales.
But what what they do is they say they
have a research vessel and they kill
them for research,
but they're not research vessels.
They take them to chop them up and they
sell them.
But they're still doing it like it's a,
it's,
it's a big deal in Japan apparently to
dolphin.
Yeah.
Well dolphins is different animal,
but this is Wales.
There's still go wailing.
They still kill whales and pull these
giant ass fucking whales on these boats
and there's photo like seat,
see if you could pull up the sea
shepherd photos,
sea shepherd photos,
see sea shepherd captures uh,
or uh,
catches,
um,
ship with whales on or something.
It was just really disturbing because
like they have,
they figured out some loophole or the
law,
you're allowed to kill them if you're a
research vessel.
So like,
you know,
all you have to do is just pretend
you're a research vessel or perform a
couple of tests,
whatever is compulsory whenever you have
to do.
And then a cell,
all the whale parts,
it's just like you hear that thing
saying and you're like,
Whoa,
you can't kill that.
I,
that's like a water person.
It's like a weird water person.
What does that see?
Separate catches jet gold go larger with
that.
So it gets,
it just catches Japanese.
Sweet.
Oh my God.
Look it up.
That's just where they slaughtered the
whales in there.
Oh,
that's fucked up,
dude.
Look,
you can see the whale parts and shit.
It's just a look at those three big ass
wheels sitting on the floor of this
Japanese vessel.
This is a real recent too.
Yeah.
Japanese fleets.
He Click on that link so we can hear
what the story is.
Sees Shepard Catches Japanese Fleet for
Wales dead man.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
as many as these people go out and catch
doing this,
a catch in the act.
How many people are getting away with
this?
The ocean's a big fucking place.
Sea Shepherd only has so many boats.
Ooh,
horrible,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's,
is it illegal in Japan,
they've found inside a southern ocean
sanctuary.
Sea Shepherd said that it had located
all five Japanese vessels now in
pursuit,
forcing the harpooners to cut short
their operation and retreat.
The group released footage and
photographs showing three minutes key
whales dead on the deck of the factory
ship.
Nissin Maru and set a fourth.
Also believed to be a minky was
slaughtered when she separate sheet sea
shepherds,
helicopter flew overhead.
There's three carcasses on the ship.
A fourth carcass has been cut up.
There's blood all over the place.
The meats carted around on this true
ship deck.
Awful.
I don't know what awful.
A O F f a l n innards being dumped in
the ocean said,
see she separate Australia,
chairman Bob Brown.
And this is from 2014.
Is that what it's from?
Yeah,
mis.
They kill whales.
They're there.
There's something about that thing that
just that like listening to that sound.
I don't think I ever heard that before.
If I did,
I never really listened.
That's a,
that's freaky man.
That's just,
that's a freaky sound.
Did you ever see that video of those,
um,
the people that were inside the
submarine when the whale came to visit
them now,
dude,
that's when you get a sense of how
fucking big whales are.
These people are in this,
I dunno how deep they are,
but they're deep in this giant ass
fucking whale come swimming right by
them.
Like right up to the side of the craft.
They're like,
whoa.
Like he could see them looking through
this thing out of fucking whale.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
You find that one.
It's a,
I forget what kind of,
some kind of a submarine.
Some kind of underwater expedition
vehicle and the submarine.
Right?
Oh wait,
wait way bigger.
Look at this.
Here it is.
So here's his people.
They're looking through this window and
um,
where sperm whale,
it's a sperm whale.
So look at this.
Look at this.
That's a way right there.
Watch this thing as it gets closer.
It's fucking crazy.
Do look at this.
Look at that.
Look at the fucking size of that thing,
man.
It's just swimming right next to you.
That looks,
that looks like a video game,
man.
It looks like that vr virtual reality.
I know.
It does,
right?
It goes right under them.
This is insane.
It's going right under them.
Wow.
That was deep seed photos from that
Russian fishermen.
Yeah.
Crazy,
crazy psycho alien
stuff with teeth and yeah,
there's been a bunch of new ones that
they found.
Was that,
that go shark.
That thing's insane.
There's two of them.
One of them that,
uh,
the Whitney coming sent me on instagram.
Uh,
that is a fucking crazy.
It's some bio luminescent shark.
She said that to me on the twitter.
It's a bio luminescent shark that lives
over a thousand feet under water.
Yeah.
This is the ghost shark.
Look at that thing,
Brian.
That's a real fucking fish.
Oh yeah.
That thing was alive in that form before
the dinosaurs.
Yeah.
Go Shark.
How crazy is that when you could find
something alive today that was
absolutely alive.
65 plus million years ago.
What a,
what an amazing time we live in.
We can get a glimpse of that and just
sort of use your shitty little monkey
brain to try to figure out like how many
different forms of life are there?
Like how,
how,
how long has this thing been going on?
Where's it going to,
okay.
You hear that whale talking.
Look at these things they found wow.
Deep Sea fishermen has been posting is
fines on twitter and it's legit.
Terrifying.
What is that?
Hold on.
That's that one fish.
Is that?
That's an angler fish.
Yeah,
but look at it.
It's blue and black.
Oh my God.
What a monster.
What is that thing that looks like a
frog version of it or something.
What is that?
I've seen that one before.
That crazy eel looking thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
That's adorable.
Yeah.
That looks like a nemos buddy.
Look at that thing.
What in the fuck?
That's the chest burster from the alien
movies.
Yes.
That's exactly the teeth.
Oh my God.
Look at this fucking hole.
He's breathing or something to Jesus
Christ.
Probably for finding prey.
What is that?
A shark?
Some kind of shark or something.
Read to,
I have no idea what it says in Russian.
Oh my God.
Look at these photos guys.
Thanks guys.
Okay.
Homeboys twitter page.
R,
F e D.
Like our fay door stuff or something.
Fed doorstop are fed door stove.
No.
Sov.
Sov not s t or s or salve salve,
right.
Hi.
That way how you'd say it?
That looks like a muppet.
Oh my God.
That doesn't look real.
Look at the eyes on that fucking thing.
Oh Wow.
It's just so amazing.
The variety of life.
Look at that fucking eyeball on top of
its head,
dude.
It's on the bottom,
I think.
No,
that's the top down,
is it?
Yeah.
What are those eyes on the left and the
right.
That's not an eyeball,
isn't it?
Or the mouth is this for,
that's the top of the mountain.
Is that a real no,
no,
no.
That thing's at mouth is open and it's
looking right at you.
That looks like a bass.
Pick up a little soul from Margaret.
That's right.
Side up.
No,
that's an eyeball,
bro.
It's Kinda eyeball on its head.
That's crazy.
Okay,
Google.
Is there a fish that has an eyeball on
it's fucking head?
Because that's the thing it says right
here.
It's just a halibut and looks like a
cyclops.
Yeah.
So that's a halibut.
Oh.
Oh,
we're just looking at it.
Weird.
Okay.
So if that was flattened out,
what's so dark?
I didn't know how that ever got that
dark,
but the angle holding it up,
it looks like a cyclops cause you know,
you know what habits are.
They're flat and they have the eyeballs
on one side.
It's so weird.
He ever seen a halibut in real life.
The fucking so freaky looking pictures
here.
We pulled up like how did this evolve?
That way they get to a spot and the
ocean they lay down on the sand and then
they shake themselves and they become
one with the sand.
Like they put sand all over their body
and only their eyeballs poke up.
You ever see that?
It's crazy.
Like how the Fuck Whoa,
look at that thing.
Yeah.
How that sandwich,
they don't google that.
How bit in the sense see watch.
You can see how it does it.
It's crazy when you watch them do it
cause they just swimming along and they
find a spot and they pound on the sand
until it covers them.
I'm looking at this,
it's great
and that's how he hides.
What a weird creature.
When they have the two eyeballs on one
side and the other side,
no eyeballs and they're flat like that
is a weird looking animal dude.
It's so weird.
It's eyeballs or poking up and it's a
Predator too,
which is even weirder.
I mean,
that's not something that's like eating
plants and shit.
It's waiting for something to fuck up
and get near it.
Look at Jack them like this.
This is a weird camouflage method and
they're delicious.
I'm not a fish guy at all.
Really?
Yeah.
I,
I think I need to get that something,
I need to get into it older.
I get the type thing because I,
I hate fish and I just hate the taste of
fish.
I like hard shell,
like lobster.
Yeah.
Stuff like that.
But fish,
unless it's cooked delicious,
Lee,
which most of the time it's just fish.
Uh,
I can't get into it at all if it's just
something that like if you go to like a
Chili's or something like that,
right.
And you order fish,
it's probably not going to be so hot.
Right.
But if you go to like a fish place in
order to fish,
I mean,
what do I know?
Maybe Chile's are the best fish ever.
Maybe I'm just a Snob,
but I'm like,
they can't fuck up chicken breasts.
You know,
chicken breasts are pretty fucking
simple,
but if your fish is old at all or weird
at all,
no Sushi on Sundays because they can't
ship it.
Never go get fish on Sunday.
Yeah,
they say even is a bit of a problem.
Yeah.
I don't know when the right thing,
it's like an old rule.
They probably can ship stuff on Sundays.
Now I get deliveries on Amazon prime.
Does he get deliveries on Sunday?
Yeah.
Nobody's more arrest.
Not Mail.
No more rest for anybody.
They're going to come to a time and it's
not that far in the future where there's
no more truck drivers.
I was,
I've been reading a lot about this man.
This is weird.
The number one job for white men in this
country is truck driver.
Wow.
I made that up.
I was going to say,
wow.
I would believe it.
No,
but it's something.
It is high,
but I did make that up and close this
one.
Or if they are going away for sure
they're going away 100%.
Find out how many people drive trucks
because it's something,
it's some amazing statistic.
Like how many,
I think it's the number.
I do believe it's the number one job for
men is truck driver and the window
transportation in the US or the world.
US to be a truck driving woman.
What's that guy to be a slut?
I'm just now I'm just,
that was a joke.
But like what do you have to be like?
That's a,
that's a weird person going to like to
be around dudes.
Miss been like a family thing there.
Approximately 3.5
million professional truck drivers.
The United States.
According to estimates,
American trucking association,
total number of people enjoyed employed
by the,
uh,
in the industry,
including those in positions that do not
until driving exceeds 8.7
million.
Um,
wow.
Find out what percentage though,
what percentage of men,
uh,
like instead of how many truck drivers
in the u f saying what percentage of men
working driving trucks?
Uh,
uh,
that's a bad question.
I'm not answering it right and not
asking it right.
Like,
um,
percentage of men that drive trucks for
a living.
Proof of that percentage of male truck
drivers,
percentage of,
yeah.
Percentage of men who drive trucks for a
living topped out at 20% are women of
all trucks hours.
When this article he expects about 10%
of the freights,
9,000
haulers to be women,
which is almost twice the national
average.
So that's double.
The national average is about 20% are
right.
But is that the NAF national average for
any job or for truck driving?
For truck driving.
Okay.
So let's find out what the percentage of
people that drive trucks are.
Because I think for men,
just,
just google what percentage of men drive
trucks right here?
A 5.8%
of the 3.4
million truck drivers last year were
women.
Okay.
So 3.4
million truck drivers and that's from
2010 or 2011 compared to 4.6%
in 2010.
Huh.
So that's saying it's declining.
2% are fuckable as this,
I think it's one to 5.8%
of the 34 million truck drivers last
year as compared to the 4.6%.
Okay.
So there's more female truck drivers now
and it's not 4.6
million.
I'm reading,
I'm reading it wrong that most female
checkers working two person driving
teams.
Good move mother daughter pairings.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good move.
Stay safe.
Lesbians.
Keep a gun.
Don't say Lesbians Brow.
They just know.
I bet.
I bet they the,
that's a big thing.
You know they would like being on the
road together.
Go on a road trips,
having fun here.
Lesbian.
And maybe what if you start fighting?
What have you like halfway across the
Goddamn country,
you gotta make the next 2000 miles.
This bitch who won't even eat your ass
anymore.
I'm so tired of her bullshit.
Oh,
you think you're too good for me?
This is,
um,
it's a weird time when it comes to those
people because those jobs are gonna go
away.
They're going to have automated trucks.
All jobs.
Yeah.
Fast food.
Fast food's going to go away before
trucker's cashiers.
I think the cashiers are going to go
away.
Sure.
But I don't think truckers,
I think it's going to,
I think the trucker thing's going to
happen sooner than you think.
They already started using these drone
trucks,
right?
Thanks.
Yeah.
I think they've already started using
them.
In some places it's a,
you're going to have to figure out a way
to employ those people.
You've got millions of people,
millions of people that don't have a job
anymore because I'm,
but there is there more jobs opening up
of things like twitchers youtubers,
you know,
be,
if they could figure out how to do it.
But I mean,
not everybody figures out how to do it.
That even does it.
How many people figure out how to make a
living off of,
uh,
doing anything on the Internet.
You know,
even people that do it,
how many people that are on like
instagram,
they do it all the time.
They do it all day.
How many people are making nothing?
You know,
zero lot.
They just do it because it's fun.
They haven't figured out how to profit
off of it.
You can't just expect these truck
drivers to figure it out.
It's like they're going to be,
what the fuck,
man,
there's no jobs left.
That was a legitimate job,
but get out of school,
there was always these commercials for
truck company's truck driving companies.
We need drivers.
Do you have a safe record and you're
like,
man,
I'm going to be a driver.
You can earn $16 an hour and you're
like,
oh shit.
16 an hour.
You know all those commercials,
those are going away.
The job that doesn't exist,
probably drone drivers now or something
like that.
Even though those are going to be
automated too,
you're going to send those things like a
navigation signal for awhile.
You'll need people to fix it.
It's a fixed PCR repair till robots know
how to do it better than you can for
awhile.
Fuck man,
there's too many of us.
We out fucked our resources.
Maybe that's what's going on.
We've got to back off.
Fuck.
I wonder if it's going to get to the
point where like,
you know like chain restaurants like
Chili's or whatever,
like in the back they have,
they're going to need just like not even
have cooks.
It's just going to be like plate comps,
squirt the Alfredo,
squirt the noodle,
you know it's going to be longer.
We're going to use that meat material
and make it with a three d printer,
like westworld style when they're making
the body,
put your fucking New York Strip together
that way.
I wonder if it's going to be better.
Imagine if you like you make meat in a
factory and it's never been worked out.
So it's like super attend.
Are you biting through here?
Like oh my God.
And they figured out how manipulated.
So it was like double the protein 15
times the iron.
No.
And the Matrix,
that guy had left the matrix and he's
like,
I don't give a fuck if the steak tastes
I know it's fake,
but I want it to,
I want that fucking fake taste of butter
right now.
Yeah.
He knew it was fake,
but he didn't care cause it tasted
amazing.
Yeah.
That's might be going on right now.
Might be going on right now.
It's entirely possible.
We're in the matrix.
I think so.
I know you do.
Finally I finally killed my other rat or
I got the,
I got no,
I didn't kill it back.
Got it out of my house.
I can't get it out.
It got trapped.
The first rap,
uh,
broke his neck,
you know,
second wrap.
Got his leg trapped.
Yeah.
You saw that and uh,
and yeah,
it hasn't been back since the back.
He might be dead.
My Dad said that if you,
if a rat sees another rat get hurt or it
gets hurting a rat cage,
they automatically know never to go back
there again.
Like never date.
That's why they're so hard to catch
because if they see another wrap in a
trap,
right in a trap,
they know go.
All right,
don't touch that silver thing,
you know?
Yeah.
It makes sense.
I saw that video that you put off
though.
It was crazy dude.
Audio audio of that mouse screaming and
that's like a monkey,
doesn't it sound like a monkey?
Yeah.
Listen to this.
We'll crank it up.
Crank that volume up.
There it is.
There's this little island like that
out.
So it's freaking out.
It's got its leg trap.
Does that,
what's the lag is trapped at home when
that happened?
No,
my girlfriend was and she was texting me
Brian,
there's a monkey in the kitchen now it
goes back up
and this is the last time I ever see me.
He goes into my cupboard and so that's a
hole in the cupboard?
Yeah.
That's how you catching them?
Oh,
so that's all contained inside the some
little box.
So he was getting in there and eating
your food.
He didn't get to eat any of my food.
He could only get underneath my kitchen
sink.
But when we opened up the kitchen sink
after we found out we had rats,
all our cleaning supplies have been
drank and ate.
Oh,
why are you showing me different things
back and forth?
Hold on,
hold us to this.
A different,
this,
a different camera angle,
but hold on.
Don't distract me.
Like tell me what your shut,
what is this one?
I was just getting back to that cause I
was him talking in the middle.
I was getting off of that.
So this is another rat now this is that
same one different camera.
Oh,
okay.
So did you get a camera with the rat?
We killed it.
Yeah,
we have photos of that and yeah we have
the video wasn't as good though,
but the photos are pretty cool.
So when he jumps through he's heard it
all.
Yeah,
but he hasn't been back.
But what's weird is that day they drank
and ate all my cleaning supplies.
And so like there was a thing of bleach
that had been eaten through and drank
watts.
So they had been living off my cleaning
supplies.
The eight bleach?
Yeah.
All my shit.
Ammonia uh,
wax for your floors.
Floors.
It's all gone.
And there's just a hole in it where they
had drank at all.
And what the fuck?
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Google.
What can rats eat?
Can Rats eat?
Cleaning?
Surprise.
I think.
I think they're pretty much,
you can't kill a rat.
And watching them the last three weeks
was just amazing,
seeing how smart they are.
And have you seen that Morgan spurlock
movie rats on Netflix,
but awesome.
Yeah.
And just the trailer,
they're like,
they're,
they're saying and how rats are getting
smarter.
They're about to overtake us.
And I believe it though,
just watching my rack,
I always obsessed with them.
I was watching him all night.
I had three camera,
shoot,
Morgan,
don't be so silly.
But yeah,
that's a horrible feeling.
Having rats in your house.
And I've had it before.
Yeah.
I want him.
I want to move,
even though they're gone.
I just don't want to be in that house.
And I would tell you the rat in my
garage story,
no,
from Encino.
And I lived in Encino,
a kill a rat in my garage.
Put this trap up.
That's where I used to keep my trash,
kept it in the barrels and the garage,
and then take it out in the morning
right when you're supposed to.
I fucking killed this rat.
It dies in the,
in the trap.
I look at it,
it's a big fucking Rad.
I was,
Whoa,
that thing's
huge.
I was like,
all right,
I don't,
I'm lazy.
I don't feel like taking care of it now.
I'm going to go take care of it in the
morning.
So I wake up in the morning and go out
there.
It's eaten.
They ate him.
I mean they ate him down to the tail.
All that was left was the tail.
She's,
and I was like,
Holy Shit.
First of all,
it taught me,
even rats when eat rat tails,
which is interesting,
right.
Tells me this tastes like rat ate his
friends asshole.
He got to the tail is like enough with
the,
I draw the culinary line.
Like they,
I mean they ate the fuck out of this rat
when I tell you that.
It was like almost none of it left,
but it was like there was still meet
that was trapped in the,
um,
in the jaws of the mouse trap,
the rat traps.
So he could tell that he had,
it wasn't like it was all gone.
Like there was a lot left for,
you could tell they ate them,
but it was like they had eaten almost
everything.
He'll all the innards gone.
Fucked up.
Eye Balls gone face gone.
They just ate the fuck out of their
friend,
ate the fuck out of him and he did it
overnight.
I don't know how many rats were in
there,
but it's a fat ass rat.
Think about if you had to you,
me and Jamie had to eat a whole person
at night.
She says,
I'll fucking,
how could you eat them?
How much?
How much meat is that?
That's insane.
Like how many rats are there that they
ate my whole rat in one night.
I mean you'd have to like,
okay,
if you had to eat a person,
you,
and if the three of us,
you know how to recruit a bunch of
people to help us eat someone the size
of Tony Hinchcliffe not a big person.
Take an hour.
No take fucking weeks to do it.
The bones were throw away the bone.
We would have to get like a hundred
dudes to help us.
Yeah,
you throw away the bumps.
They ate through those fucking bones.
They ate,
they ate most of the bones.
How much meat can you eat?
A dinner like two pounds maybe may,
you might be able to force three pounds
in your face,
but you're going to feel like shit.
So the equivalent for a rat is like you
eating 50 pounds.
I didn't know they jumped so high.
I didn't know that was a thing.
Right?
It's jumped high like two on topic to
your counters and like that was fucked
up dude saying that they're freaks.
They can scramble up things.
They'll attack you,
make out into my wall heater and fuck my
heater up and like blew the pilot out
and did something.
Like they really fucked me up.
My dog like wouldn't leave my bedroom.
I wouldn't leave my God.
Dude.
Well think about a dog that's like
having a rat and the size of a dog.
Imagine that like a rat the size of a
German shepard living in your house.
I think that rats documentary started
because they were a rat terrier thing.
There was that.
There's a group of people that take
their little dogs,
Johnny Olson and they fuck up rats.
Yeah,
it's fine.
It looks fine.
Yeah.
Break their backs.
Don't even eat them.
They just fuck it.
Do it like for fun.
Well that's what those dogs are designed
for.
They made those dogs in Europe.
I believe I might've made that up.
But uh,
they made those dogs just to go after
rats.
Yeah,
I still have to get one.
Please Google.
What percentage of white men drive
trucks?
I was,
I was driving me crazy.
I've got to find this out.
I was about to get cats again.
I was about to get that rat terror.
Call me up,
man.
I had come from borrow one here.
Now you can't,
you don't want a cat.
They shit in a box in your house cause
awesome as they are.
And if you leave them out to kill the
rat,
that's what I was going to have tony
laid there with his butt up in his pants
down in the kitchen and consult wall,
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Don't get it.
I was not going to kill the cat.
Richard Gere.
Richard Gere,
like the rat would go in that,
but nevermind boy though is bad.
Jesus tried everything,
but you got rid of your rides.
I mean,
yeah,
you got up,
you got to do it right.
You got to kill him with fucking traps.
You gotta and you got to set out poison
and you've got to have someone to do the
whole thing.
Otherwise they'll take over your fucking
place.
I think luckily for the last week and a
half,
there hasn't been one rat.
So what's one reason why I'm pro coyote?
You know,
even though coyotes have eaten my
chickens,
they've killed at least one that I know
of that might've killed too.
I think that coyotes are super important
for keeping the rat population in check
and the mouse population in check.
Somebody told me if we just had more
Guinea pigs like live like that,
they would take care of all that.
Hmm.
Like Guinea pigs hate rats and mice and
Guinea pigs.
This are kind of cool.
I wouldn't mind seeing those guys.
Well,
there was a show one anthony Bourdain's,
a old show.
He did an episode about this family that
lived in South America and apparently in
a lot of places,
Guinea pigs are eating on a regular
basis and they keep them as pets.
So the entire floor of these people's
house,
like where the kitchen is,
just Guinea pigs running all over the
place since you grab one of them,
killed them,
Cook them up.
That's weird.
They're so stupid.
They don't even know their friend died.
Whereas Mikey,
they're not like rats.
They're just like their pets in there.
You know?
Even if you,
it's me,
it kind of,
it's kind of what you're doing.
If you kill chickens,
you know,
it was just,
these early is wandering around with
you,
but they're well fed and then when the
time is common,
the family needs to eat.
They just grabbed one of those
motherfuckers.
I pick any pigs.
Good.
They look good the way they were cooking
and it looked like they've done it
before.
All right.
It's probably super lean,
you know,
it's probably a lot like rabbit or
something like that.
I don't like rabbit.
You know,
there's Mites that grow on rabbits that
can kill you.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That if you get bitten by these Mites,
they carry diseases especially um,
like got jack rabbits like a lot of
jackrabbits have them.
And if these,
uh,
it's a really important to be careful
because if you don't,
if you don't handle them with gloves or
if you get them on your body and if you
get the wrong kind of like,
you know,
like ticks carry lyme disease,
some ticks do,
some mites carry this horrible fucking
disease that kills people.
And if you don't get antibiotics in you
at the right time,
people have died from like killing a
rabbit and eating it from the mites
biting you.
Like what in the
fuck?
I was scared that this rat was going to
like this rat jumped on Janice and my
girlfriend is like,
it touched her like,
well we didn't,
we thought there was only one rat and
then so we were like cleaning something
out in the kitchen and she picked up
like the Styrofoam thing and it was
attached to the style of like what?
Like,
it wouldn't let go of it.
Like when she picked it up,
looked over at her and it just jumped.
And you know,
luckily it didn't bite her or anything
like that.
What if it got caught in her hair and
was just fucking chewing its way out?
Eddie if sent me,
he has rats right now.
He has a huge rat problem cause he lives
with Eddie lives in a very rural area.
Yeah.
Santa Monica mountains or something like
that.
Right.
Well where he is,
it's like this fucking coyotes and
mountain lions and all kinds of shit.
Yeah.
What is that?
A keyboard touched on an ipad.
Yeah.
Now why,
why that over a laptop?
Oh,
I use a laptop.
I just,
this is,
uh,
my dream for drawling like deejaying
from like kill Tony and stuff like that.
I could pretty much do everything that I
can,
uh,
on this then my laptop.
Right.
But it doesn't have any storage.
Uh,
yeah,
it's got stores.
But I mean like you can't like make a
file.
Right.
And like leave it on your desktop.
So there's certain things like that I
need to do that for.
I had as a memory,
like you can store movies on it and Oh
yeah.
Songs and stuff like that.
Yeah,
it's great.
I love this.
This is,
and you know the cool thing is is you
could just carry it around like this.
You know,
it doesn't have to have the keyboard and
the stewardess doesn't give you a hard
time when you're watching a movie like
that.
But if you use the keyboard,
you're a bad person.
Right.
What the fuck is that about?
It makes no sense.
Like you have to close your laptop,
but you'll have to open up your tablet.
Explain how come,
how come I can hold onto a tablet and
it's safe.
But if I'm messing around with the
keyboard,
I might blow this fucker right out of
the sky.
It makes zero sense.
You have to put away your laptop,
but you can hold onto your ipad.
What?
I'm going to white,
this laptop has such a huge brick.
Like that's cause it's a really good
laptop.
Yeah.
But I mean if you get the lay windows,
I know,
but if you get the latest Mac book pro,
like the highest specs ever,
it doesn't have a break like that.
It has a little power thing but well I
have a backup brick that's a smaller
brick than that.
That's a big brick.
Oh No,
that's a brick I bought online because
it is a Lenovo brick.
I think it just works on a lot of
different laptops and they make a giant
one too.
That's like a 17 inch one.
They still make a 17 inch one.
That's a crazy burke.
This is a for me,
like when I switched,
people keep asking me because like most
people just use apple stuff and they
stay on apple stuff.
The hardest thing was trying to use an
android phone.
I abandoned that.
The reason why I abandoned that,
it's just too many fucking people send
me messages and it's,
there's no real,
and I contacted a lot like a contact of
you and a lot of people.
I called them up and I said,
hey man,
do me a favor.
Change the thing on your phone that says
I have an iphone,
change it to just mobile and tried to
send me a text message.
I'm going to send you a text message to
tell me if you get it.
And nobody was getting,
they
were getting my messages but nobody's
messages.
We're getting back to me,
they were going Osi messages.
Hold on a second.
It does go both ways but I never got the
messages back.
But I even contacted apple and I said
pull my email off the I message server.
The email that I used to have connected
to it and they pulled it and I see it
still wasn't going through.
So I waited a day and then after a day I
was thinking,
I was saying like 50% of the texts I was
sending,
we're going through his tax and people
replying as techs 50% the rest of it was
like a big struggle side.
Okay fuck this.
Like they make it really hard.
All the Greens that I know,
like a constantly we're having problems
like why didn't you text me back and go,
what are you talking about?
And then I look at their phone and they
sent me something or I sent in
something.
But the communication between android
and apple operating systems is not,
they're still like,
it's not 100% because I've never
experienced that.
I've never experienced anybody sending
me a green message and I mean not
getting it,
but fucking for sure.
Once I switched over to Android,
it was a disaster for a solid day and a
half.
I was,
and I was in the middle of doing
business stuff.
I was like,
I can't do this.
I need to,
I need to be able to answer questions.
I need to be able to,
you know?
So when you try to switch over to
windows,
it's easy.
Windows is easy.
There's windows 10 is great.
It works good.
I like,
there's a certain,
a bunch of things.
It's different.
Weird shows me different pictures on my
desktop.
If I decide to every day it shows me
like new cities and new nature settings
and stuff,
I can open it with my fingerprint.
You know,
there's a lot of like,
like the password works with my
fingerprint,
the keyboards.
Amazing.
It's a way more comfortable experience
typing because I was,
I used Mac books for so fucking long and
they are,
they're still great,
but Mac books are metal and metal
doesn't feel as good in your hands.
Like this plastic,
I haven't kicked me sir.
Ah,
Nice.
You're like,
look at this man.
When you want to start this bitch up,
you put your fingerprint in there.
The new Mac books have the thumbprint,
but they,
they're the new keyboards.
Awful.
I,
it's like it's,
it doesn't click anymore.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like spongy or that's the thing I
liked the most about this is that the
keyboard,
like when you hear,
when you timelessness.
Yeah,
it's like a,
it's like you have like some travel,
you have traveled to the keys,
you know,
and I think for someone who writes,
like from me,
my fingers have to be comfortable so I
can just,
I know where the letters are.
They've got to be comfortable.
So like,
Oh yeah,
this is,
I get this and when I don't get any
feedback,
it's not the same loop of information.
So it doesn't feel as good.
Like if I tried to type something on
those virtual keyboards,
I've tried to type things.
It just feels so weird.
I never know where am I putting my
fingers in the right place in the wrong
place.
It's just not as good as what apple
changed their keyboard too.
That's why it feels a little different.
They called butterfly.
I like it or some shit.
And what's the difference?
I don't know.
It's just a little softer.
This is the old style scissor mechanism.
So the old style,
you feel more of a click?
Yeah.
See I want more.
Click me to this new one.
Felt mushy.
That's what it felt like.
It mushy.
Yeah.
I want to click like what I like about
this,
like feel this tap,
tap those keys.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
And it's like shaped like a little half
moon.
Yeah.
You know like the bottom of it has,
it's,
it's got like a little dividend.
Your fingers sit in there and you know
when you start moving your keys,
like the apple ones are really flat.
Flat on it.
Yeah.
That's one of the things that I don't
like that much.
What I like about this Lenovo,
this thinkpad is that there's like a
contour,
like a uh,
a pool in the middle of these keys.
Like there's,
there are lower in the middle and higher
the ends and your fingers float right
into that spot and they feel like it's
giving you feedback.
She was like,
you can even tell by this photo that
Jamie has a look.
There's barely any difference between a
non push button and a push button and
the kind of like depth there is,
it's barely anything I need more.
Me Too.
You know,
like I need more.
I,
they're trying too hard to be like slick
looking and futuristic and minimalistic
and the experience of using something is
like,
there's,
this is a big issue with the car world,
you know?
Yeah.
Because w with new cars,
cars are becoming more and more numb to
the experience of driving like the
steering's now electric instead of
hydraulic.
And you're,
you're like,
you're power steering feels weirder.
You don't like,
you don't feel it all,
it feels very universal.
No matter what you do,
it's easy to turn the wheel and then the
body doesn't give as much feedback.
The suspension is more improved because
it absorbs the ground better so it feels
kind of like you're floating.
You don't feel like when the tires are
going to break as much as you used to in
the old days,
like in the old days,
if you had an old car,
like if you had like um,
like a old nine 11 like that's a perfect
example.
Like a Porsche nine 11 those cars were
super light and it didn't have that much
power.
It's one of the things that people don't
realize like an old porsche has probably
less power for sure than your truck.
Like what do you think your truck has?
What kind of truck do you have that that
Ford Edge,
but it's a four by four v six yeah.
So your [inaudible] probably has like
260 horsepower and let me guess,
pull,
pull up Ford edge horsepower,
2008 let's take a guess now thinking
about this.
This is a truck,
right?
It's a big ass truck.
It's got a lot of body to it.
They were go bangle.
I nailed.
Damn.
Okay.
Now a porsche nine 11 from like 1973 I
want to say maybe as 140 or 150
horsepower.
Let's find out.
Sutton nine 11 porsche nine 11 1973
horsepower.
Not popping right up or would it be the
best place?
Just Google horsepower portion?
Not In 1973 Porsche nine 11 stock
horsepower should have it on Wiki said
it increased from 190 to something.
Does that sound right?
Maybe it was a turbo.
Do they have a turbine 73 I don't think
they did.
Probably not.
Anyway,
uh,
your,
what do we got?
Sorry,
you said nine 11 yeah,
yeah.
No,
and that's the word.
The right word.
Nine 11 career.
Career means race in some fucking,
what does that,
you think German doesn't seem like
Carrera sounds like in a time where it's
got Italian.
What's that Jim?
Uh,
I see 200 developing a 210 ps or two 10
to land.
210.
Okay.
So if that's what it is,
your,
your truck has 50 more horsepower than a
porsche,
which is like a super sports car and at
the time,
but um,
that car is so light that you feel
everything like with those,
those old Porsche's,
like you feel every bump in the road
when the tires start to give out,
you kind of feel him given out like you
feel in your butt,
like you know,
when it's happening.
Whereas with,
um,
uh,
modern cars,
man,
they,
they go numb.
You don't feel them anymore.
That's the same thing with like
electronic stuff.
Like I have a mechanical keyboard on my,
on my home computer.
It's like a real clickety click,
click,
click.
It feels,
is your home computer pc or Mac?
It's a PC.
It's a macro.
Okay.
Mac.
Um,
but uh,
but I would use a pc for home computer.
I have no problem.
I don't do anything,
man.
What do I do?
I write,
I write on this,
they,
and then also there's a program,
one of the big issues,
like I've talked about that right room
program that I use all the time.
There's one that they make this even
better for a windows,
it's called the focus.
It's called focus.
Right?
Or something like that.
Let's see,
what is it called?
Career is race and Spanish.
Ah,
there we go.
It was named after a race.
The car was,
I've been looking at pcs just because I
want to get the one of the,
either the Oculus or the HTC vibe.
Yeah.
Focus writers.
The name of this program that I use,
but it's the same thing as the right
room,
which just gives you that uh,
oh yeah.
Green Font with a black background.
It's like dos.
That to me is like the most important
thing about writing.
If I can get a program like that on my
computer,
what else does it need to do?
As long as it doesn't fuck me,
it doesn't let just crash all the time.
And thinking about these think pants is
they use these,
these are military spec and they use
these in a lot of like big businesses.
They don't want these things to fuck up.
So these are,
these are like a,
it's a very durable computer.
It's so durable that a lot like a lot of
these people,
they don't,
they don't even recommend wicked windows
10 they want windows seven it's like
they sell it with windows seven as an
option and I've seen windows seven it's
like Jesus Christ.
What do you mean the nineties here?
Windows xp pro.
Yeah.
They go back because it's like super
stable.
Like it's been worked out and yeah,
you don't need Mac anymore.
It's nice that they innovate and they
keep coming up with cool shit and their
phones are still awesome.
But the experience on a windows computer
is in Miami is snuck not much different.
It took me like how long Jamie?
A couple of days I was,
this thing's great.
It's,
I'm not,
I don't have a problem with it at all.
I don't miss it at all.
Is that a gaming at all?
You can is,
this is not the best one for gaming.
This is a work computer,
but the battery life is fucking insane.
It looks like it has a great dad.
Actually,
it looks like the laptop.
I sewed you when I lived in Ohio that I
went to the airport and I got fucking
flag for it.
There's a smaller one,
a thinkpad p x to 60 or something like
that.
I think that's it,
but it gets 17 fucking hours.
17 hours of use online with no,
with not being plugged in.
Yeah.
I'm looking at a alienware and Razer as
the two is the new one that they just,
this thing that qh deep razor laptops or
like there were like super high end
laptops.
There's a beautiful,
yeah,
they're all aluminum.
Well,
you know like the,
it looks a lot,
a lot like a Mac book and a lot of ways.
It's like a aluminum pc version of a Mac
bar.
Yeah.
Jamie,
you have an htc.
Do you use,
do you use a laptop?
I got to go.
I want it to be a little more stable.
Uh,
I didn't get the best,
highest end thing you could get.
Did you just go to like best buy and
just grab a computer?
I went to fry's,
I found something that was,
I could've got it at best buy but they
didn't.
The actual computer I found I wanted to
get wasn't available at the store at the
time.
It was back ordered on different places.
I've found it somewhere in California.
I could go get one.
I got at my hands that day cause I had
ordered a five and I didn't want it
sitting around staring at me and I
couldn't use it.
So I went and got something I can play
with.
I do almost nothing on this computer
other than web surf and right,
right.
Yeah.
That's it.
It does everything.
And this thing also has to fucking
terabytes.
Two terabytes of storage in it.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
when the,
the new Max in have a USB port,
I was like fuck you.
But did it.
The new computers did these new laughter
pc when still have this one does this
has everything.
This has htmi.
This thing has everything.
It has a smart card reader.
It's like they just keep making things
less and less convenient and no options.
Like how about you have one of those and
then you have one.
Let's go crazy with some fucking USB
ports.
How about you have one that has a
disposable battery?
Let us know.
Like cute.
Can you make one with a replaceable
battery?
Isn't that possible?
It fucks keyboard on the razor.
That's that's,
yeah,
that's green.
Look at that.
Had,
oh my God.
What a special hotkeys set up to
whatever you want them to be.
Some hot keys can be a male.
Some hot keys could be youtube.
Wow,
that's dope.
I didn't know.
Blast off and it's super thin.
Know how much do they,
um,
yeah,
I'm just exactly echo this stealth.
I'm not sure if this is actually this
stealth,
this with this keyboard.
It might be a little more specked out,
but the tell starts like 1400 bucks,
which isn't very bad at all.
Especially if you went over on the
baddest ass games,
you can and it can run really bad ass
games and stuff on ultra settings with
these,
which is fantastic.
So that's the way more physical
capability than
a Mac keyboard or a Mac laptop would
rather right now.
Um,
how big did they make them?
Cause that's another thing that annoyed
me.
So when apple stopped doing the 17 inch
one,
I know they make a 17 mm hmm.
Well what APP would apple's done?
Let's see.
All,
see if they make a 17 inch one.
Yeah,
they do.
Oh my God.
17 inches.
So at the size of that thing,
let me see a big picture.
Look at that fucking science and that
thing.
Look at the blade pro.
The blade pros looks better.
But again,
here,
look,
I'm sure those are bad ass and they're
probably better than this for,
I'm running games on it.
And if I wanted to run games I'd be all
over that shit.
But you don't want to get virtual
reality too busy.
That playstation virtual reality really
got me.
I have a pool table game.
You can play pool.
And I have a pool table right out there.
Come on,
let's play.
But it's uh,
it's,
it's got me addicted.
Like I'm addicted to it now,
but I really want to play like the HTC,
I don't know which one to get though.
Do the vive that Dunkin has,
it's fucking insane.
And there's a boxing game that you play
on it.
Yeah.
It's kind of weird because you too,
for the knuckles to come out like this,
like they would,
if you're punching somebody,
you have to hold your hand upright so
that the bottom of your hand is facing
the ground and your thumb is facing up.
So that's the only way you get the
gloves to look right.
So it feels weird because you're
punching them like this Kinda,
yeah.
Like you're not turning your knuckles
over,
but that's just in your head.
Like if you,
if you could get over the fact that the
knuckles look different on screen,
you can just turn your hands in and
punch like you normally would,
but you get a workout doing it,
man.
It's like a real workout.
Yeah.
Like you're boxing against the dude.
You're moving.
And he's throwing punches at you.
You're just trying to get out of the way
and he hits you like everything lights
up,
it gets white.
Like you just get hit.
Yeah,
I want to do it
can get all the,
I'm pretty sure of this too.
You can get all the oculus games on the
vive.
You can,
you can do it the other way around.
Does a program something,
does it the vibe have more cameras?
So it has,
oh the larger,
it uses something called room scale.
So there's two,
you can buy more if you want.
I'm not sure really why he would want to
buy more yet.
But it comes with two uh,
lighthouses,
what they're called.
You play six and a half feet off the
ground and they figure out like where
you are and track,
you track the headset,
check your hands in the room.
So they always kind of know what's right
low,
what's left.
You don't have to keep switching your
hands around.
Wow.
There's another game that Duncan had
that's an archery game that's fucking
amazing.
It is.
When you draw back and they're,
they're raiding the castle and like,
yeah,
they're coming out and you need to shoot
at him.
They're like circles with like shields
in front of them and spears on go.
Do you think,
would you say you did that with Dunkin
timber?
Maybe?
Yeah,
probably around then.
Just in that amount of time from now til
then.
There's three cooler archery games that
have come out.
There's like a hunting experience game
where you're like walking around the
woods.
You know what I would really like?
I would really like if they made one
where I can use my real bow.
Oh that'd be cool.
Cause if I could use my real bow and I
could draw it back,
it would have to be in some sort of a
secured room.
You take off the headset and there's a
bunch of dead people everywhere.
But um,
but it would actually help you because
of the weight,
the weight of the bow.
You want to feel the exact weight.
The biggest issue right now with that is
that that headset gets in the way of
when you're trying,
like you draw the ball,
you put next to your head that yeah,
it would hit your thing because as I'm
doing it now,
I'm just pulling it back like this on
Dunkin's,
but I know there's a video game.
Let's look this up.
Maybe this will be a new thing for the
the,
the new studio.
There's an archery game where you
actually shoot at a screen and animals
walk in front and you shoot a real bow
at the screen and where it hits,
it lights up like yes you are.
Oh cool.
You're shooting a real fucking Arrow at
a real screen down with that.
Yeah,
like we'll get this real tree whitetail
country.
I don't know if this is it.
Okay.
This is it.
Yeah.
Techno Hunt.
Okay,
so watch this guys got a video and he's
standing in front of the screen.
He's going to shoot it.
Okay.
Can we say,
Oh yeah,
look at this.
So it looks like it's about 40 yards
away.
Not even,
I should say 40 feet away.
Watch.
This is going to shoot at it.
Perfect shot right there.
That's stupid.
You would shoot through your screen
immediately.
No,
but that's what he just did.
He that that stuck into the screen now.
That was a,
that was a picture of an era.
So what is it?
A fake error right away you see the
Arrow bounce off?
Wait a minute,
let me say it.
Let me just do it again.
Do it again.
It's just like from 1982 I think.
No,
no,
no.
Hold on.
So he hit it and it shows where you hit
a big fake arrow.
That's a fake cow.
But he actually did hit it where the
fake Arrow points to pick out.
Just indicating what spot on the screen
and he's out hit the wall to,
yeah,
listen,
I hear it again.
We'll just slip one in there.
But you're,
you're super powerful.
Bo would shoot some shit through a wall.
Right?
You would want to use a less powerful,
I think you actually have to like Cam
Haynes was playing this game and he told
me they had a de tune,
his bow and a,
I think at the time he was shooting with
a 70 pound bow.
I think he was shooting with a carbon
spider turbo,
but I might be wrong.
But at the carbon spider turbo,
they don't,
they didn't make that any faster than 70
pounds or any more weight.
I think it's probably a feet per second.
And um,
kinetic energy thing,
like the hour we'll probably has to be a
certain weight too,
but it would just be more fun.
Or what'd you actually getting benefit
out of practicing with something that's
less powerful than what you usually use?
Um,
there's a different feel to a less
powerful bow,
but the principles of archery or the
same as long as you hold right,
pulled through the shot,
anchor in the same way.
Use the correct body positioning.
I'm going to do archery.
Dude.
Archery is awesome.
I love doing it.
It's so fun.
And,
uh,
if it wasn't for my friend Cameron Hanes
and my friend John Dudley,
I wouldn't know shit about it.
It takes a long time to learn.
Okay.
This is a different one.
So this guy is doing it here.
Boom.
Oh,
that's better.
Let me see that again.
Backed that up again.
So he shoots and where does his Arrow
go?
So it does bounce off the wall.
Yeah.
See you have to use a bitch ass bro.
And I'm just kind of a rubber point at
the end.
They can make better wine.
Yeah.
Well it's good practice for sure.
This is,
see like he's hitting perfect every
time.
So it's good practice for that,
for aiming the vitals and all that.
Exactly,
exactly.
But it can't be more than,
this is like 20,
um,
20 yards away.
It looks like big bucks on game.
There's,
you're not,
you're not getting any hunting value out
of that.
It's just no shoot,
fix shit with a fictional,
but this is,
they're shooting a real bow.
So to answer your question,
the difference between shooting like a
50 pound bow with these light arrows,
it bounced off the screaming like what
benefit you would get.
You'd get a lot of benefit.
Like you don't need a big heavy bow to a
to get the benefit of being accurate.
Like people are accurate with like
really,
really light bows and that's really all
you'd worry about as long as you had the
strength,
how rude they gonna shoot a rabbit as
long as you have the strap right in the
eyeball.
Bullseye.
Okay,
stop.
Who is the name of this company that's
rude and shot it in the eyeball and it
says Bullseye.
I feel like I could design a better
version of that.
Well,
it's probably super hard to make
something where you can actually shoot
something on a screen and it registers
right,
like find out.
I bet that's expensive as fuck.
That's probably same technology that
does the golf course.
Oh yeah.
But,
but the difference in the golf thing is
a golf is a ball.
You're knocking it into a screen.
Fastest Shit.
Not as fast as a bow,
but you could probably have something
where it's just going in a different way
though.
There's a point in the end of a bow or
an arrow rather.
Yeah,
I bet.
A golf club,
when you hit a golf ball,
I bet it does go faster if you really
drive it,
does it?
Okay.
How many feet per second do you think
someone drives a golf ball?
Feet per second.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jeez.
How many feet per second is tiger woods?
Knock a golf.
Oh,
John.
Who?
Who Hits it harder?
John Daly.
John Daly hit it harder than tiger
woods.
You See Tigers Nipples,
his nipples.
He did.
You see at Jamie,
he released a naked or not ne,
a shirtless photo and his nipples had
been the talk of the town.
He's got nipple.
It's time to move to a new town.
You live in the wrong fucking town.
If all they're talking about is tiger
woods,
hey,
open up man.
Have you heard about tiger samples?
What is,
look at what's going on with his goatee?
Is that real?
It's something somebody said he does for
his kids.
It's like bad ass answer some shots.
It's a loophole.
If I was Brendan Schaub I would say for
sure don't do that anymore.
Um,
what is the um,
feet per second of the golf ball
hundred.
You had to take me on a nipple detour.
Huh?
How many feet per second does a golf
ball?
50 travel 150.
How many per second does a golf ball
travel?
Let's see.
Okay.
You say 5,950
150 probably more than that.
That's probably about as fast as a bow
and arrow.
250 feet per second.
Yeah,
that's good.
Terminal speed for a,
an arrow.
Oh,
like that's what you want.
The rule is that you can't hit a ball
faster than that.
And the Oh,
Sga,
what?
You can tell someone they can't hit it
faster.
Maximum tolerance of 2% will be allowed.
What?
I don't get like a what if you get some
dude who's like,
okay,
how about this?
What if like coby bryant goes into golf,
like think a super athlete,
driving a golf ball perfectly.
It's more like,
so a hundred you can calculate with your
swing and the,
the weight and the speed of your driver
clubface and all that.
Uh,
and then balls way different amounts to,
it's maybe because there's people
standing around and you could fuck
somebody up.
You're fucking a mock no matter what,
man,
he hit him 200 miles an hour in the
face.
You're fucking a month.
I don't know.
That's ridiculous.
[inaudible] 72 is okay,
but imagine if you did have a guy like
a,
a Koby Bryant or like our Lebron James.
It gets an a cough like Leblanc.
Lebron James gets a cough and it can
knock a fucking golf ball to the moon.
But uh,
that's about the same speed an arrow
goes.
If it's a good heavy air,
like a lot of people like to try to keep
their arrows actually under 280 feet per
second,
like pursue between 280 and some people
get up to like two 90 ish,
but they feel like when the arrows go
faster than that,
they actually,
the flight gets compromised.
It's like there's so much.
Yeah.
Because there's almost like too much
wind resistance.
There's too much a,
there's like the wind impacts the way
the thing spins.
What does this long drives?
That's guy hitting about 200 mile an
hour ball.
Okay,
but what does that in feet per second?
Oh No.
Cause just google t 206 miles an hour
equals feet per second.
Find out what the fuck that means in
feet per second.
We think it is 302 okay.
So that's about what you would expect
from like a top and bow with a fairly
light arrow.
But like I said,
most people try to keep their Arrow's a
little slower than that,
believe it or not.
So what they would do is they'd make a
heavier arrow.
So like if you had a 400 green Arrow and
you were coming in at 302 feet per
second,
a lot of people would tell you you
probably better off with a 450 green
Arrow that comes in around to 70
something like that.
Yeah,
to 70 to 80 yeah.
You want more control?
It's more forgiving.
And also it has more impact,
like a light Arrow going really fast as
undo the damage that a heavy Arrow going
fast does.
So I same difference in golf than so
they get more control over their boss so
they can sell.
So it lands somewhere they want it to
land as opposed to just go on.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's the thing with pool to the break
shot and pool.
Like there's arguments that uh,
like there's a guy named Shane van
boning who's probably one of the best
breakers in the history of pool.
He breaks so good but he doesn't put
near the effort into it that all these
other guys do.
Some other guys throw their body into it
like karate,
like they're fucking trying to kick
through a wall and [inaudible] and they
have this crazy impact on the balls.
But Shane,
what he does is he stays flat on the
ball and he just strokes through it
perfectly.
So the ball is almost never,
um,
in the air.
The problem with hitting pool ball,
like this guy is ridiculous break shot.
Like you can't tell from that picture,
but I've seen him do it live a bunch of
times of,
of actually watched him play in person
several times.
He's fucking amazing,
but he doesn't hit it as hard as other
guys do.
He just hits it more perfect.
When you look at like high speed
photography of a pool cue,
when a guy hits it really hard,
the ball is actually in the air,
like when it's in the air,
when it impacts,
like see how it hops like that too.
That's also just from the force of it.
But look at all these balls fucking
flying all over the place.
It's ridiculous.
Like he's a,
he's a freak in that regard,
but it's just perfect accuracy and
precision.
It's just,
it's a matter of like the perfect
mechanics and the like this loose like
fluid motion fluid and efficient motion
and that's what they say is the same
thing as about golf.
That driving and the ball that it's not
about muscling it right.
It's about like driving through it.
Yeah.
Like when I play pool and I'm playing
good,
like I'm never really good,
but when I'm better what happens is I
get to a point where I'm just like the,
the q's doing all the work.
I'm just like letting,
I'm like moving into the spot and I just
like let it just sorta like,
I don't ever tighten my hand up on it
and I don't punch it.
It just flows.
And when you do that,
it's crazy.
Like you see the ball moving way more
than it normally does.
It's weird and it's just like this fluid
and efficient impact that it has with
the ball.
And I guess that's the same with golf
and with probably with everything,
right?
I don't know about everything but golf
is definitely that you need,
it's like don't,
don't grip and rip.
Somebody will say grip and rip it.
It's how they do it.
But like you shouldn't be swinging like
a baseball bat,
like swinging for home runs.
You're not going to succeed necessarily.
That's the same as fighting.
But in finding the other way works to
fight.
It's weird.
It's like there's no hard fast rule.
Like someone can come down,
bite down their mouthpiece and real
fucking haymakers and catch you in the
Chin and knock you out cold or someone
can.
Conor mcgregor,
you like the way conor Mcgregor Aldo
mode when he,
when he knocked out Aldo with one punch,
13 seconds into the fight,
the way he did it was just precision.
He just slid back on a back,
just dropped it in there and all those
face went squirrely and his brain went
off.
I mean that's like the perfect example
of precision versus power cause with,
although does he bites down on his
mouthpiece,
any wings is vicious.
Left Hook.
He throws us right hand like this and he
throws his vicious left hook behind it
and it's all to try to set up the left
Tuck.
Connor slides out of the way,
drops his left hand in on Aldo while all
those throw in the left hook and then
left hook kinda makes impact on Connor's
face but probably didn't have much more
than momentum behind it because all it
was already out.
Like the punch was perfect.
That's got to haunt you.
But the way he did it,
man,
it was just all precision like watch.
We'll play it,
play it back again.
Watch this now.
It'll play it from the beginning.
There you go.
Watch it.
Slide blank.
See,
he got tagged like right on the
cheekbone and that could have been a
double knockout.
Imagine if he got tagged on the Chin on
the point of the chin.
That guy is a savage.
I'm so glad people like conor mcgregor
exists.
Look at this.
Boom.
Just flattened him.
One shot.
Blam Bam.
That's some strong mind.
Power their baby.
To be able to stay that calm in the heat
of a firefight and just slide out and
just precision.
Drop a punch in a box.
Dude.
Foamy Brian,
look,
you fall asleep.
Yeah,
guys gone.
What happened to you either?
You know I,
I'm on tod.
TMD.
So at the snapchat talking about conor
[inaudible] you don't have character,
but that the comparisons to snatch to
connor,
like the character of that,
whatever Brad Pitt was.
No,
it's terrible.
That guy couldn't talk.
That's the character.
That's fucking terrible.
Who compared them?
I see stuff online.
People are so stupid.
Most people should.
You should have a license to talk.
Oh it's the worst.
You'd have to,
you'd have to go through in order to use
social media you should have to like go
through an extensive test.
You're like people are so addicted to
twitter and instagram and all that
stuff.
You should go through an extensive like
spelling tests.
I should.
Well how do you say you are?
Do you say while you are or did you say
you are,
do you say y o u Apostrophe r e or that
no you are.
Does Eddie still do that?
Remember when he used to do it long time
ago he was going hard with the texting
early on.
A lot girls do.
Getting rid of comment sections.
What like that for places for people to
comment way?
Well like vice is one of them.
It's not a bad idea in some serve
certain circles cause some things it's
interesting like I love reading science
articles where people start debating
like uh,
the legitimacy at certain points or you
know,
what,
what are the options for considering the
evidence?
Is there anything else that made,
maybe it's being overlooked and you get
some really interesting responses from
people that actually understand the
subject.
But man,
as soon as it says anything to do with
politics or gender,
those two fucking things,
man,
those two things,
everybody gets nuts.
There was a video that MTV put out.
Um,
it was a new year's resolutions for
white guys.
It was one of the worst fucking,
most racist,
sexist videos of every tweet that it was
so ridiculous.
Like I imagine if anybody had ever made
a video like that about any
generalization,
about a hundred million people and what
it is,
it's a general,
like if you say,
how many white guys are in America?
Let's,
let's just guess how many white males
are in America.
Not Enough.
Princess Leia is dot.
Had a heart attack.
She's okay right now though.
She's stable.
Okay.
How many?
62% of the US population is white.
62% of us.
What percentage of white males?
White,
white males,
the majority,
which is about 77%.
That's how many white males and males
though,
white men or 31% of the population
there.
Okay,
so we're 31% of the population is 350
million people.
Somewhere around a hundred million
people,
right?
It's in that neighborhood between 80 and
a hundred million.
Right?
That's what a crazy thing to generalize,
like just to make a video about white
men.
She was like,
hey white guys.
How about you get your shit together?
Like just white guys?
Just white guys like,
Holy Shit.
Do you want to do this about black guys
too?
Why don't you see what happens when you
do it about black guys?
How about you do it about black women?
See how quick somebody beats the fuck
out of you?
How come you can do that about white
guys like this?
The idea is that white men are the
privileged and that white men have this
advantage,
so you should attack that advantage by
being racist towards them.
I was,
the best way to stop racism is to be
racist towards people who you think are
racist.
It's hilarious.
It's so stupid.
It's so like,
it's,
it's unbelievable that MTV news stuff,
they should do a video like that.
What's really bad?
Mtvs the worse.
I mean,
have you watched it on TV recently?
I'm sorry?
Do you,
do you like MTV?
No,
I try,
I to watch TV anymore.
I don't have cable anymore,
so I have,
you know,
a psv or whatever or a sling and,
uh,
so I have certain channels I normally,
but not as many as I used to have.
So like,
I'll watch mtv more just because I have
it.
It's one of 30 channels,
but MTV is just garbage channel now.
There's nothing that we're too old for
it.
That's like,
you have to be 18 to 22 to have any
food.
They have that show.
What does it ridiculous is that on MTV?
God,
that shows just saw a bunch of like
videos of people getting jacked on the
Internet.
Right.
And then,
um,
everything else is,
they don't have videos anymore.
Right.
It's not,
you know,
videos on Youtube.
Every videos on Sunday one.
What a weird time.
Yeah.
But you know,
it was cool and they had videos as you
learned about new bands because you saw
their video.
Yeah,
but nobody wants to watch those anymore.
I guess they played videos versus people
falling on their head.
People go to fall on their head every
day,
so they just went where the money is.
So this is the idea is that like they're
just trying to appeal to social justice
warriors by making this video.
There's one girl in the video,
she goes find out what mansplaining is
and then don't do it.
Hell like find out what like what a
ridiculous idea that you can be
condescending about someone being
condescending and that that somehow or
another is going to work like that.
All the thought,
making a video like that,
it's exactly how trump got elected.
When you tell people what to do,
they automatically want to do the other
thing.
Even if they wouldn't want to do the
other thing if you hadn't said Shit.
But when you push people and you tell
people just if you make up ridiculous
standards the way people are supposed to
behave because you think they should
behave like that and that you are
allowed to make gigantic gross
generalizations about an entire group of
100 million people just because you
think it's open season on white guys
like that is how people like trump get
elected because people push back against
your ridiculous political correctness
and go towards what's the enemy of that?
What's the enemy up political
correctness that pussy grabbing guy,
let's fucking vote them in and that's
what happens.
That's exactly what happens.
These people are,
the people that are so mad that trump is
in office are directly responsible for
it hordes of people voting for trump
because they are sick of where the the
PC generation is pointing.
It's an irrational point of view.
It's not objective.
It's not,
if anything has to do with gender or
homosexuality,
whoever has to do with any of those
things is no longer considered as an
individual.
Then you're considered as a part of an
untouchable group that is almost always
exonerated of anything they've done
wrong.
It cheats.
You get to this weird fake world where
people aren't people anymore.
They're figureheads for ideologies.
That's a problem with political
correctness as much as it's a problem
with people that are super right wing or
people that are born again Christians.
Right.
It's fucking up comedy like so many
comedians have been talking about
lately.
How like they've had to stop themselves
on stage,
you know,
and not go down a route.
They normally would always go down
because of the recent,
you know,
racist shit and a pc shit sewed much
different,
you know,
in the last even six months.
Well there's definitely more pushback
but there's always been pushed back.
Have you noticed a change?
Have you,
have you noticed like certain things you
won't say now or do now or,
well it makes you just back up what you
want to say better.
It makes you reinforce your arguments
better.
It makes you,
if you're going to have something to say
to people,
you have to have,
you know,
you have to have a real point and you'd
have to be able to back up what you're
saying.
You have to be able explain what you're
It's why I did that whole bit about am I
not my last,
not in triggered the Netflix special,
but the one before that,
the comedy central special about words
about how like you can't,
you can't just decide that jokes aren't
real
okay.
Or rather the jokes are real.
Like when someone's telling a joke on
stage,
like,
you know,
that guy doesn't mean what he's saying.
So that's why when I'm in that special,
I said,
I'm going to say some things that are
true,
but I'm gonna say a lot of shit that's
funnier than the truth.
So I'm going to lie.
Like if it's Funnier to lie,
I'm going to lie.
Like you got to know.
Sometimes I'm gonna tell you the truth,
you know,
and I go and sometimes I'm going to say,
shit,
that's not true at all because it's
funnier than the truth.
Like,
here's some truth.
My wife is tired of fucking me.
And then people say that quite a bit.
But,
but,
but she never says no
because if she did,
I'd raper and I'm like,
I'm joking.
I would never rape her.
See,
that's not true.
I go,
the worst I would do is hold it down and
titty fucker butt cheek.
I wouldn't do that either.
These is not true statements.
I would never do that thing.
She's the mother of my children.
I wouldn't do that.
But you could say that.
And you know,
I'm not being honest.
You know that's not true.
You know,
that's,
that's a joke.
You know,
when someone says something fucking
ridiculous like that,
that they don't mean it to joke like,
like when Brian Holt's,
when used to have that joke about that
woman who drowned her kids,
he goes,
I heard those were bad kids.
I heard they sat that close to the TV.
They never put away their blocks.
The kids would not be missed though,
is spelt their milk.
No.
It's like Holy Shit.
But you knew that he didn't really think
that,
which was the whole point of it.
That's the problem with today is people
just looking to call people out for shit
they don't think people should say
anymore.
You know?
And in some ways,
maybe they're right.
I mean,
you'd go back to old stuff like go back
and try to watch Eddie Murphy raw and
you're like,
wow,
I don't know if I'd be laughing at this
now.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that shit too,
right?
I have no,
I saw,
fuck.
What movie was it?
Something something so innocent like I
like ghostbusters,
the original ghostbusters something
where they called somebody a certain
name.
Like I think it was like they said
Chink.
Hey,
yeah,
yeah.
Cenk like,
like,
whoa.
It was just like back then I remember
going Oh,
chinks and had that bad.
Now there's no differentiation between
shank and anything else.
Any other slur,
spic,
Chink and Spic,
or they're all the same.
Pretty much the racist bugs bunny and
stuff from back in the day.
Yeah.
We've got Japanese people.
Funny Nips the nips or say,
well,
that was during World War II.
Yeah,
man,
we've changed.
Human beings have changed.
It's just funny when it comes to comedy,
we just have to be clear that we're
fucking around.
Like people are allowed to say things
that they don't really mean like,
well,
we were talking about this Donald Trump
thing when he was interviewing that guy
or it was on a bus with that guy and he
said a bunch of shit about,
about women guys do that for fun.
They say shit like Joey Diaz is the
master at that.
He'll say unbelievably ridiculous shit
to you that you know,
he doesn't mean you know,
and you'll be just be crying,
laughing.
You know,
he's talking about stabbing people
about,
we're throwing them out the fucking
window and he doesn't mean it.
You know?
He doesn't mean it,
but it's funny.
What do you got to new screen doing
nothing.
I was just like going to talk about
something later and I said,
what does it now I want to spend problem
with it.
That's why I tell you to put those
things away.
I want to continue always.
You always want to start surfing.
You're so addicted.
I'm not addicted.
You got to have a conversation.
You can't just stare at that fucking
screen.
Those goddamn things will suck you in.
They do.
They suck you in,
dude.
You can't help it.
I start talking.
You're like,
well,
I'm not talking right now.
Let me just sharp this web here real
quick.
Sure.
No,
I was just trying to find it.
I just hate when instead of going,
well I think this and this and that,
I'd rather like go,
okay.
It is true.
So before I even go back down that way
you don't get it.
It's kind of like live fact checking,
but just
ask Jamie.
He'll check it for you.
He's trying.
No,
don't remember about what would you want
to talk about?
Nothing.
Jesus Christ wasn't sure.
What was it that you thought you were
just talking about?
I don't know.
You weren't at a point about what you
were talking about now.
I can't remember what it was about.
You were just talking about Donald Trump
and Billy Bush on the bus talking about
Joey Dia saying ridiculous things that,
you know,
he doesn't really mean that anybody
doing it.
But the thing with Joey is,
is that he says ridiculous things mixed
with things that are true,
but you don't know which they're real
and are fake.
You know,
journalism bugging the fag in or are
true though.
Yeah,
I know it's true.
But how much is true?
Like you know the shit out of him.
He told me that story a long time ago.
He tried to sucker punch this guy and
the guy was gay and the guy knew how to
fight and the guy beat the shit out of
him and he's beating the shit out of him
while I was calling for the cops.
You've got,
you got new in a box or the guy that he
liked,
the guy brought it over all the cocaine,
you know,
and he like,
he went to jail.
Joey's a liar.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying you're in trouble.
I'm like,
God,
I think you're missing.
You know what I'm saying?
That he has stories like those mixed in
with stories that aren't real.
So it's like you're really confused that
like you know,
which is real and which is not probably
the only one confused.
No,
no.
Like when he's telling jokes.
Yeah.
I mean all right Jamie,
does joey confuse,
you know,
seems pretty direct.
Yeah.
Cause it,
cause it seems like when you know some
of the stuff that you think is that Oh,
physicists jokes or his ridiculous stuff
might actually be real.
Well the problem with Julie's,
his life has been so crazy and so
colorful so that he'll still to this day
tell me stories that I haven't heard
before.
I'm like how do you have more stores?
Yeah,
exactly.
But he does,
it's just whole,
I think his whole life from the time he
was like a little boy until he was like
into his forties was just chaos.
So he's just has a good solid 30 years
of chaos stories,
like legitimate chaos stories.
Have you seen this new specialty?
I don't see.
So you just coupon code joey for two
months.
Have you seen it yet?
I have not seen it yet.
Have you seen it?
No,
I haven't.
I that's one of those weird networks
that are like,
yeah,
you got to sign up,
right?
Yeah.
And it's weird to cancel I probably or
something.
I hope it does.
Well,
I really do.
And I hope,
uh,
I mean,
cso of course,
I hope Joey's thinks does well,
but I hope also the,
they put port their stuff to other
places once they get their money back.
So a lot of times they'll do that.
They'll sell them again somewhere else.
If somebody special just was released
like on Seeso,
like Nick Thune or something like
yesterday and it says available on
[inaudible] and Amazon.
Hmm,
that's a good deal.
That's you're going to get the dorks on
Amazon.
But how many people are really using
Amazon to watch movies?
Like netflix would probably be like way
ahead of Amazon.
A lot of people don't know that.
If they have Amazon prime,
do you get access to that APP?
It's also,
you get,
you don't get everything because they
try to,
uh,
they work in,
they're like rental movies and stuff in
that APP too.
Right.
You get a decent amount of content for
free.
There's a whole music app you get to.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
Um,
they also have that top gear show,
which they said is the most illegally
show in history.
Wow.
The new one,
the new one,
they said the first episode in
particular is the most illegally
downloaded episode of a show ever.
So I'm way more people download it
illegally than watch it on Amazon.
Well,
it is crazy because they,
they paid a shit load of money for that.
And the idea is that,
well,
once it gets on Amazon,
a bunch of people jump over to Amazon
because that was the number one TV show
in the world that,
that show top gear with Richard Hammond
and James May and those guys that that's
there a giant team.
I mean,
when it comes to like the whole world
watching a show,
that's probably the most watched show in
the world and it's on Amazon in general.
It's just them driving around mostly and
just like talking shit to each other
talking shit.
It's funny.
They're funny to fire somebody recently
that was on that show.
The,
yeah,
the main guy.
He,
what's the fuck's his name again?
On the main rovers version?
I'm the one that's in the BBC.
Yeah.
Chris.
No,
no,
the the the the real one.
Yeah.
Jimmy Claxton.
It escaped me that weed.
I've been in the weeds but Jeremy
Clarkson's hilarious.
He's really funny.
He says a lot of fucking hilarious shit
and he talks shit about companies too.
He talks about he reviews cars in a way
that like no other no American show
would ever be able to do.
You never be able to get away with it.
He shits on them like he shits on
Porsche's.
He hates Porsche is it calls them like
vw bugs and Bionics in four k which is
one of the things.
Is that good?
Like I say,
same with Netflix originals.
It's one of the only things.
It's a four k content for your new four
K tv.
If people are looking for shit,
this is hard.
It's hard to find.
So anyway,
people take and then they upload it and
it's just uploaded like crazy all over
those bit torrents and all those
different sites and just millions and
millions and millions of people are
downloading it.
So you've got to think of how much
Amazon paid for it and then how few
people are actually using their service.
But if you had to guess like how many
more people use netflix than anything
else as far as like Amazon or Hulu or,
I use Hulu more than I use netflix now.
I barely use netflix anymore.
I use Hulu all the time now.
What do you get on Hulu?
Uh,
like all the,
like the local channel is like really
like stuff like that you get local TV
channel.
I mean like the,
like the NBC shows that CBS shows that
Fox shows the news and all those other
things like NBC News.
No,
I get that on sling.
Uh,
and Psu.
What's that?
Playstation you sling is like,
uh,
like live TV.
So,
but you can pick and choose which way
you want.
Like I just like NBC,
ABC,
CBS.
I have like a food network,
you know,
things like that.
It was like 40 channels,
you can get the best one.
It's playstation now.
Well there was um,
my friend had Alexa,
he has Amazon and that you talk to Alexa
and shuts the lights out and it does all
that weird shit.
But [inaudible] and uh,
he had a bunch of channels when I was
looking at his stuff,
I had never been seen before and one of
them was like all Montreal comedy
festival.
It's like all people that I knew
performing in the Montreal comedy
festival,
it's like this is weird.
Oh,
not Alexa.
You're talking about Amazon fire like
that.
Yeah,
the box.
But he has Alexa,
like you talked to her.
Oh,
say Amazon.
You say Alexa,
please turn on the TV.
Alexa,
turn on channel five.
I have the Alexa that looks like a Mug,
you know that Alexa.
But my point being is that there's a
bunch of channels and I never even knew
existed that are on this essentially
live TV.
They have programming.
So you're watching it just like you
would watch direct TV.
Like if you were to watch directv now,
one channel becomes,
one show becomes the next show becomes
the next show.
He just watched them in a series.
They play out in route.
They had this on these weird little
channels.
And I'm like,
how many of these channels are there?
And he's like,
there's a lot of them and they're
growing.
And I was like,
well,
this is television.
This is online television.
Like this isn't just like a Netflix show
where you tune in and then when you plus
play it starts.
No,
these things have a schedule.
Like this is on from seven to eight.
This is on from eight tonight.
It's fucking tv,
but it's online and it's streaming.
Like,
Whoa,
this is different.
Yeah,
there's a lot of those and a lot of them
have apps now,
so you can just download the app on the
Apple TV.
Here's the problem.
What's so fucking great about direct TV?
What's so great about [inaudible]?
What's so great about their choices?
Like it's in terms of like entertainment
content,
how many white he's fucking go shows you
to put on,
you know,
oh,
another guy cooking.
Whoa.
Let me tune in now.
Oh look,
orders.
I've got a certain point in time.
Right.
Well,
uh,
I've been doing this too for like about
a year.
I've been,
I cut my cut my cable channel.
Most of these,
cause I still want to watch live sports.
I still watch NBA Basketball Games are
still a couple of football games.
I want to watch from time to time and
though it'll freeze and at the worst
time possible when the quarter's about
to end or some really important so it's
going to happen.
Or if you're watching the UFC fight,
you lose out minute of around in the
middle of the third round of the last
fight or something.
Like there's definitely bullshit or
that's the difference on your directv or
at and t or time warner.
It's just a,
what we're used to.
It always comes in,
unless there's like a giant storm that
cut everything out for the entire
country or whatever,
it's all,
well always works
for now.
It's going to get better.
It's way better now than it was 10 years
ago.
Thinking about how bad it was when you
first got online.
Real player got real everything,
everything.
Almost everything.
Anytime you watched a youtube video,
you had a pause and wait.
You were living in an era when it comes
to the accessibility of stuff and as the
internet gets stronger and stronger to
signals are getting better and better.
I mean,
we're on four g l t e now,
right?
Like what's,
what's five going to be like,
what's six?
What's seven?
How,
you know,
how powerful is that stuff going to be
in terms of download speeds?
So when they get,
like when you hear like a 97% work,
everything works 97% of the time.
You don't want to be in that 3% of the
time when it doesn't work.
Yeah.
Well I know a lot of people that get
stitcher on their car,
it's like a native app on their car now.
And so they're listening to this podcast
right now on stitcher,
directly from their car and their car
picks up the Internet.
Right.
Without having to plug your phone.
Yeah.
Like if you have a cadillac escalade
when those new ones,
it comes to the builtin Internet
connection.
So you're driving around,
you turn your fucking car into a wifi
hub.
Yes.
We should be driving around like you
could park and get on the Wifi of your
fucking truck and I mean this is just,
you know,
step one of a million step process our
phones at home then soon.
No,
no,
never.
Never.
Almost.
No.
Jamie's Jamie's fighting for it.
No,
you're going to have that chip in your
head just like that Black Mirror show
here.
That's what's going to happen.
It's amazing how close that Black Mirror
episode was to all these different
versions of recording your memory that
we had come up with.
Oh,
that's so funny.
It's going to happen.
So funny you said that because that's
definitely what I thought.
I thought every single episodes like
there,
they're listening to jre no,
no,
no.
Those,
I think way more likely is that those
subjects are being repeated by a bunch
of curious people all over the world.
Like the ability to record memory.
Everybody knows that's comment and their
take on it was really pretty unique.
But like all the different,
all the different possibilities that
we've ever discussed on this podcast,
there's a lot of other people talking
about them.
It's not just us.
There's a million different people
speculating as to where the fuck is this
all going and virtual reality and
particularly like there's not a single
person that could say I'm the only one
who's predicted the,
the,
you know,
the future of virtual reality.
Like if you were talking about virtual
reality for sure you got it from me,
that's impossible.
There's millions of people that have had
like pretty profound thoughts about the
potential for virtual reality.
No,
it's just that if you,
the watch the whole season,
it seems like every episode is like a
different thing that you've talked
about.
Like remember when we said a long time
ago,
uh,
how I thought like likes are going to be
currency and stuff like that in the
future.
They have a whole episode about that
that gets,
so when other people have thought that
to make sure,
I was talking about a yelp review for
people like a long fucking time ago
about like people having floating stars
above their head.
Like when you walk into them you go,
oh,
this guy's got four stars.
Must be a cool dude.
I call,
he bought his fucking stars.
And you find out people are buying their
stars like you.
Like if you find that if you go to a
yelp review and it's like a Vietnam
restaurant and all the fucking reviews
are in broken English,
best noodle ever have you and no for me,
this is my place.
Exclamation point,
exclamation point.
In the same way,
like the same like shitty broken English
and every review you'd be like,
I think these motherfuckers are writing
their own reviews.
Right.
But if you've ever gone like a yelp
review or any kind of review for
something and you know the people
probably bought those reviews.
Absolutely.
You can tell he grossed out,
right?
Yeah.
They have no other review.
No other reviews except that the people
that if you go to their instagram page,
they got a million followers and like
last week they had 300,000
or 30,000
like what happened?
Were you involved in a national scandal
or he could buy instagram followers
easily and twitter followers.
Instagram is a big one though,
right?
Yeah,
I know a lot of instagram girls who
bought followers.
They're public about it though.
They're like,
yeah,
it's just so I can get more stuff.
The sports commentator got caught
leaving a comment on his own page.
Oh
No.
Uh,
great.
See that?
Ha Funny.
Skip bayless thought.
Forgot to switch accounts.
Praising himself on a facebook
livestream.
It may not have actually been ham
because it could've been someone working
for him.
He doesn't talk to anybody working for
him.
It's him like his wife or something.
No,
it's him.
You are the man.
Exclamation point,
exclamation show.
Fuck.
To get caught doing that.
To love the new show on fs,
one exclamation point,
exclamation point.
Explanation.
Oh my God.
Did he try to delete it?
I don't know.
Shit.
He,
it,
they be like fell down and hit his head.
Was that,
I hope,
I hope this is a joke.
It's a comedian revealing himself at the
Ice House comedy club on the facebook.
Like if you go to the ice house stuff.
Yeah.
Like it's under his account.
Like I saw so and so their privilege
seeing him so funny by Mertz.
Who is it?
He's someone you know,
he always starts a great party.
Do you know him?
Yeah,
we all know.
Oh no,
but,
but he's not the only one.
He's not,
he's not the only one.
There's a lot of Comedians,
so I don't know if that's like a joke
or,
um,
well some people don't understand
retweets and the copy and paste stuff
and they forget to put a rt in front of
it.
But even so,
yeah,
people have been busted before.
They get like a publicist will send out
a big message to like 20 celebrities and
they'll just copy and paste the whole
thing and forgot to change the two
things they're supposed to change to
make it seem,
oh yeah.
Original.
Yeah.
Well there's definitely that.
Definitely people who have done that and
there's also the limitations of 140
characters,
so sometimes maybe like won't attribute
it to somebody that somebody else said
it.
You fuck up and then you go,
what did I just do?
I don't know who that guy is.
Is he a big time guy?
That guy that yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Really get bayless.
Really?
Yeah,
he's the first take.
He used to be on espn,
now he's on Fox sports.
Oh,
just talk shit.
Talk Shit.
Really Weird fucking take on Ronda
Rousey in the last fs one thing,
the last Fox thing and I remember
watching that going,
this guy should shut the fuck up.
Just trying to say anything you can to
get attention on a day to day basis.
Not
really.
They should shut the fuck up.
He's talking if he wants to,
but I,
I was,
I felt like you didn't know what he's
talking about.
I felt it come through.
I was like listening to him talk about
it and kind of made it kind of good
point about,
I think he was talking about her.
I'm taking the time off and all this
stuff and I don't think he knows a sport
that well,
I might be wrong.
I don't think so.
I might,
I might be wrong,
but it just didn't,
it seemed to me like one of those clear
examples of the main stream adopting,
like I take
on something that they don't follow all
that closely.
Like a lot of people love to be right
about fighting.
It's a big one,
man.
They love to be right about who's gonna
win,
who's gonna lose.
It's one of the reasons why I don't,
I hardly ever give predictions.
So you don't know shit.
You don't know what the fuck's going to
happen.
You could tell me you think you know
what's going to happen.
But until those people go in there and
fucking throw punches at each other,
anything can happen.
Anything come on mayweather that,
that highly unlikely to happen.
But if it did happen,
if they would just boxed,
probably like the biggest boxing match
of all time.
Uh,
Nate said he wants 20 million or he's
not talking or something like that.
He might've been high,
might have been high as fuck when he
said that.
Great Dude.
I've been hanging out with that like he
could put into coming to the comedy
store in a regular basis.
Now I've been hanging out with him late
night.
Yeah,
I was hanging out with him and Nixon.
Nick's great.
Yeah.
Funny dudes.
You would never know.
They could beat the fuck out of here.
He's just meet them.
You think they're so friendly.
It's,
you know,
just normal dudes,
you know.
It's fucking brutal sport man.
He deserves 20 million bucks.
They all do.
You just did Tony's podcast too.
I heard her.
It was really good.
Yeah.
I just think it's weird,
man.
When people who start chiming in about
the sport,
they do it like they talk about other
sports.
To me it seems so much more personal.
Like,
fuck man,
I've been following it forever and I,
I barely have the confidence to say what
I think is going to happen when people
fight.
So when I,
when I see people just jump in and have
an opinion of it,
it's like,
Oh man,
I guess,
yeah,
go ahead.
Man,
they're trying to get all controversial
about stuff he's trying to,
I've,
uh,
I played basketball in high school,
but I still like,
I watched it for my whole life and I
hear someone say something stupid like
at the gym,
just about like Lebron or the warrior.
And I'm like,
shut the fuck out of here.
You don't know what you're talking
about.
My basketball.
Well,
it's also,
here's another thing,
one of the things about mma is that the
sport is as,
I mean,
I hate that fucking Cliche,
but I've got to use it as real as it
gets.
It doesn't get any more real in terms of
like raw emotion and consequence.
So as a show,
when you're watching it on television,
I don't know if you're getting a 100% of
that,
if you're there,
I think you get more of it.
But it's,
what it is,
is,
is it's so raw and so real that if
someone's not real and they're talking
about it,
it becomes real obvious.
Like,
if you don't really care,
like if you're talking about a fight and
you're getting all jazzed up about it,
if you're,
um,
if you're talking about a fight and you
get jack,
if you actually are jazzed up about it,
people can feel that.
But if you're faking it,
they feel that too man.
And in this sport,
because the sport is so,
and it's so intensely real,
it's so intensely raw and naked that
you,
um,
your la people are way,
way less tolerant to bull.
I'm good dude.
Way less tolerant of bullshit,
you know,
or things they disagree with.
It's like there's a lot of,
a lot riding on every aspect of
fighting.
Like you see the Bernard Hopkins Fight
Sad,
right?
That was sad.
Bernard Hopkins,
if 51 years old fought this kid named
Joe Smith Jr if you're,
if nobody's seen Joe Smith junior before
he's fucking,
he's a killer.
Like Bernard Hopkins picked a killer and
this kid fucked him up and his kid has
extra long arms.
He's got weird arms,
like his arms go below his waist.
I was watching him fight.
It was like,
look at the length of his fucking arms.
Like he just,
he beat the shit out of Bernard and he
knocked him out of the ring and Bernard
caught him with some good shots.
He was timing him and he caught him with
a few right hands with the kid was just
eating them and moving forward.
And you know what it looks like.
It's like when people have fake hands,
like the fake hand is like sticking
through the shirt sleeve.
Yeah.
He almost looked like a cartoon guy with
his extra long arms but he's a bad
motherfucker.
That guy and Bernard got knocked through
the ropes and fell on his head.
It was crazy to watch and he got up,
he was all disoriented,
didn't know what happened,
thought he was pushed through the ropes,
but he was punched through the ropes
that got connected with like four or
five big shots and,
and the last one was a left hook on the
face as Bernard was going through the
ropes and it knocked him all the way
through,
but it was 100% legal.
He didn't do anything wrong.
He did everything with punches.
It would,
none of it was a push.
He was just bombing on them and it just
was a freak incident.
It's one of the reasons why cages are so
much better than a ring.
A cage is so superior,
like a ring.
It's like that,
that,
that possibility that you could fall
through like that.
That's terrible.
That should,
they should stop using rings and if they
do use rings,
they should pad the shit out of the
outside area.
The fact that someone like Bernard
Hopkins who's been boxing for forever
can still get knocked through a rope
like that and land on his head that
that's a possibility.
That's a stupid way of containing people
they should have instead of ropes like
that would,
they should have is something that has a
criss cross pattern where you can't go
through it and you should have to just
climb over it to get in it.
It should be real simple and it should
be a way that they could release the,
uh,
the ropes.
Like if there was a medical emergency at
the end of the fight,
it should be like a latch.
They could pull and drop the ribs down
and get somebody out.
But the ropes,
the way they use them now in boxing
matches,
they should fucking outlaw those.
The fact that Bernard Hopkins can get
knocked through one like that.
That's cool.
Or the very least.
You've got to protect the outside area.
You got to pad the shit out of it and
you had to have,
he should have people around and most of
the time a thousand fights in a row.
It's probably never going to come into
play,
but the onetime it does.
You're responsible for that guy falling
through the ropes.
That's fucking stupid.
Like look at him.
He goes flying through men look a
little,
lengthen that kids' arms so it doesn't
look,
it looks photoshop like his head is not
the right size or something.
He's a,
he's built for it.
I'll tell you that.
He's got great genetics and works hard.
Tough kid.
Really good fighter.
Had Chin line if you like that,
huh?
Yeah.
He's an animal.
I was,
I was super impressed with his poise to
in fighting a guy like Bernard Hopkins,
man,
that guy stepped up in a big way and he
was a two to one underdog leaning into
that fight,
which is really crazy.
What's APP?
Yeah.
I was pretty convinced that,
uh,
Bernard was going to be able to stifle
him and turn it into like the kind of
fight that Bernard likes,
but I wasn't sure if Bernard could win.
You know,
it's a long time off,
two years when you're 51 years old.
It's a long time off.
He still fought amazing.
But at the end of the day,
that kid marked him.
He just was,
he was just too much and he was,
he's,
he's a guy that would have been a real
threat at any time in anyone's career.
Like he's,
this kid has real talent and right now
he's not thought of as being the best
fighter in the world or anything even
close to like that.
But Bernard was at one point in time,
Bernard,
like when he beat Felix Trinidad,
a lot of people were saying that might
be the best pound for pound box or the
earth.
Like a lot of people thought Trinidad
was going to beat him.
He fucked Trinidad up and then he fought
Kelly pavlick and a lot of people wrote
him off against Kelly Pavlik.
He box the shit out of Kelly Pavlick.
And so you look at like Bernard's legacy
and you go,
man,
this is an unbelievably skillful guy.
But at any point in that career that Joe
Kelly kid would have been a handful.
He's just scary.
He's or Joe Smith rather that Joe Smith
junior kid would have been a handful
because he's just fucking scary.
He hits hard and he's,
he's super accurate and he's got awesome
endurance and a great work ethic.
He's fucking dangerous no matter what
era it is.
And Bernard,
you know,
maybe Bernard would have been able to
beat him in his,
in his prime.
You know,
it's totally possible.
It's 100% likely.
I mean Bernard's and all time.
Great.
Maybe it would have been able to land
more of the punches that he landed in
that fight.
But you don't know.
I mean that kids dangerous boxing such a
crazy sport.
It's,
it's weird that it's a,
we all know now that it's so bad for
you,
it's so bad for your brain.
Like the practice of it,
the,
the doing it.
We know it's terrible for you,
but we still watch just like football,
just like I'm in May.
We know,
but,
well,
I think there's going to make training
smarter because I don't think the
fighting is going ever end.
Cause we like p some people don't train
smarter though.
You could train anyway you want.
That's the problem.
Nobody knows who's right.
Like Eddie Alvarez sparred like a
hundred rounds,
um,
in preparation for his fight against
Hofeld Osan Joseph sparred like a shit
load and came out looking like a
monster.
Just,
just stormed.
Dosantos knocked him out in the first
round.
But then connor,
you know,
connor doesn't his bar that much.
It doesn't spoil like that.
Like the way Alvarez was doing it.
And some guys aren't like Donald's
Sarone.
He's not sparring at all.
Donald cerrone's just doing drills and
he looks better than ever.
I mean,
he just fucking head kicked.
Mack Mack Brown.
No one's ever knocked out Matt Brown
like that.
I mean,
people have stopped him.
You know,
Jake Ellenberger is the only one that
ever stopped him and he stopped him in
the shot to the body.
How the anybody else before that?
It's stopped him with body shots.
They've heard them.
But this is like a beating,
you know,
and Donald Donald Head kicked him
unconscious.
I mean,
that was,
that's like as final of victory as it
gets.
And he's not even sparring.
He says he feels way better now,
I think
as a veteran,
excuse me,
as veteran as it comes to like a new guy
coming in,
that doesn't sound like you shouldn't be
sparring.
You should probably be sparring a little
bit to the whole key is to get somebody
who spars with you that's not trying to
hurt you,
but it's just trying to grow with you
and learn.
That's so hard because egos get involved
late.
George would never hurt you.
What?
Boy?
George.
Who would never heard you?
Oh,
all right.
That's it.
Sorry.
What else are we going to go?
I didn't know we were that deep.
What's it's four 30 oh it's almost tried
to breyer.
Oh my God.
It's going to suck.
Well,
this is,
it's the only time you can drive,
right?
Like you have a seven o'clock show.
You literally have to leave now.
How crazy is there?
Do you take 'em you know you should
take,
you should take the two 10 to go.
I went 34 to 10 and then go,
yeah,
well you can go up to one 18 you can go
shoot,
go down to Topanga.
Took the Panga to the one 18 tick the
one 18 to the to 10 you'll go,
it will take you more miles.
But then you dropped down instead of
going through this shit.
Right?
Like if you go through that four or five
like this time of the day,
I wouldn't do that.
Or the five either one of those can suck
a fat one.
Yeah,
the five just ridiculous.
Five is always under construction.
Isn't it funny how we have people in the
La talk talk like this though,
like about highways and yeah.
It doesn't happen like that in Ohio or
well they don't have as many people.
Right.
We've fucked up.
This is a great spot.
Too many people found out and they all
just moved here.
There's way too many people here.
I kind of looked us up one day to the
freeways here where all,
they weren't always called numbers.
They were called like this was like the
Ventura freeway in the Hollywood highway
and shit like that.
And then so they changed the names and
people just drop what they used to call
them and just call the one on one de
four oh five no one 18.
That's only out here,
you know,
cause it's not that many different
freeways and other places really either.
But um,
even if you go somewhere you would like
in Massachusetts you'd say you a,
you get on four or five south,
you know,
you wouldn't say it's about four or
five.
Yeah.
That's what I mean by the was only added
because they didn't refer the freeways
here as number.
Is this the one that one was only the
Ventura freeway or a highway or whatever
the fuck?
Well,
that was the case in Boston with the
mass turnpike.
Like the mass turnpike was called the
mass turnpike,
but it also had a number,
like you look on a map.
It would be the number and then the mass
turnpike,
like what does this thing,
it's like it's got a royal distinction.
The Mass Turnpike,
what does is this route 90 wait,
what is this?
Yeah,
yes,
yes.
We're done.
Whatever it is.
Yeah.
Out here is that there's a,
on the east coast,
there's no the before it.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on,
but yeah,
there were national road went through
Columbus.
It comes out to here to route 40 road
that goes from Columbus right to here.
It goes from Washington DC actually like
San Francisco.
Holy Shit.
How long does it take to drive that
bitch?
Is it the one that runs next to the 66?
Because when I moved out here,
yeah,
there was a,
there was like a dirt road that was like
a road but 66 it right along like 70 for
a long time and then it switches down to
like 10 isn't it?
That song get your kicks on route 66.
Have you ever driven across the country?
Yeah,
I've drove up here from Ohio twice.
Wow.
33 hours straight,
dude.
That is through serial killer with the
little you on whose math?
Just switching off every eight hours or
if you go to sleep hours.
Yeah,
just asleep.
I wouldn't trust that dude.
Stay awake.
Fuck that.
I made it.
Sounds like barely made it.
And I skated in time.
We had a jeep in the back of the haul
two,
which was probably totally illegal.
Drove it into the u haul and parked it
in there.
Oh,
that's so stupid.
Did you tie it down or anything?
Okay.
Well they do have those,
um,
those car transport trucks that are like
that though.
You weren't doing that.
You didn't know what you're doing.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
probably totally illegal.
And then you packed it old shit and the
jeep so that if the jeep came bouncing
out all your shit and go flying out with
it for a little bit of the people that
packed it happen and help that they ran
a tow company.
So like they kind of knew how to make a
car stable.
Could fucking fuck one of its legal.
No,
no,
no.
Take,
that's your limitations.
Hopefully allegedly,
allegedly did all that.
A lot of the things that we say folks,
it's just jokes.
It's Shuma.
So while you work with George Perez
Tonight,
George Perez,
Dean Delray topple the Bray Improv.
You can chose a funny motherfucker.
Yeah,
he's a wild dude,
man.
His stories about prison were hilarious.
He came in on the podcast and hit me
with all his crazy stories.
He's,
he's great to hang out with.
I think.
I love that dude.
And we're going to San Jose.
30th offset at the Improv have two
shows.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
And the 30th this weekend is a Friday,
right?
Is that the 30th or the next week is a
Friday.
The Ronda Rousey fight on Friday.
Yeah,
because the 31st is New Year's Eve.
Nobody wants to compete with New Year's
Eve.
New Year's Eve is time to make shitty
decisions and get fucked up.
Probably I'll be playing the Ronda
rousey fight at the show.
Uh,
illegally.
Are you doing?
I'm even say that.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
People are going to go to see that
anyway.
Yeah,
I'm fucked.
Well,
the beautiful thing about dvrs,
man,
you could,
you could go to both and you just record
the fight.
Don't,
don't listen to anybody.
Just go la,
la La,
spoiler alert and then just run around.
I hate spoilers.
I freaked out when Westworld,
I had the season finale.
Like I had to like walk force myself
even though I was tired just
to watch it.
Just,
I didn't want to spoil it.
Yeah.
I got away with it.
I got away with it for like a week and a
half,
two weeks.
Nobody told me Shit.
A duct it total toin duct.
It slid right in there.
Yeah man.
But like people get mad at it.
But here's the deal.
There's so much to talk about today that
if we support,
if we didn't talk about like certain
television shows and certain movies
because of spoiler alerts,
like,
listen,
bitch,
you've got to take your chances.
If you want things to be secret,
you've got to stay offline.
Okay.
If it means something to you,
stay offline.
Otherwise people are going to talk about
it and don't get mad at people for
deferred using information.
Right?
Amen,
sister.
Yeah.
It's that important to make time or just
deal with the fact that if you dip your
fucking nose into the information
highway,
you're going to get some information up
there.
I can't believe you don't want,
I can't believe westworld and lost this
in the same universe like it's crazy.
What the fuck up.
That's not true.
He just made that up.
But it is sort of,
it's the same guy,
right?
Could be the same world.
We never know,
but I mean,
isn't it the guy,
same guy,
Jj Abrams,
he didn't make it all by himself.
Lost,
but who made stranger things?
Somebody that's not a different group.
Some brothers,
right?
The grimm brothers or something like
that.
They have a weird thing where they like
to call themselves a fucking great show.
You shut your mouth,
boy.
I tried three times.
Now we'll go to the doctor and find out
what kind of tumor you have in your
head.
It's causing you like stuff that's
socks.
Soap stuff's awesome.
Silverstone,
how dare you.
Okay.
What's going on?
Duffer brothers,
if the duffer brothers.
All right.
I love that show.
I understand you don't Brian Gilmore
boys.
Awesome.
Love Jamie.
Do of it.
I didn't see it.
Does a new one called the o v or
something like that.
I'm when I watch that.
What is that about?
Is it science?
Fictiony?
I think so.
It looks like it,
right?
Like she was blind and she came back and
she could see and she disappeared.
Not knowing what something's about and
then just watching.
It sucks.
It sucks if whatever,
you wasted your time,
but if you find something cool,
it's the coolest way to find something.
I'm really getting in the house of
cards.
That's a great show.
God Damn,
that's a good show.
I wonder how much of that is actually
how things go.
100% it seems like it,
right?
They know so much right now about what's
going on because of house of cards.
Well,
there's never been a show like that
before.
That shows you the inner workings like
with swears and sex and all the
craziness like good fucking chat and
lots of west wing when it was out,
but I don't imagine it was as close to
reality.
Is that this House of card seems gay guy
being straight.
What?
Kip?
Acting straight.
All right Brian.
I don't know what you're talking about.
You're saying that's how it really,
you think that's how it really goes and
you know you mean Kevin Spacey or you're
trying to say I get it.
What do you want?
What do you want Brian and won a gold
star tickle you.
I got,
I wonder if anybody has been,
go ahead and pee,
man.
Sorry.
I'll wrap it up.
We'll wrap it up now.
This is it.
The end.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
We will see you soon.
Happy,
happy a happy seven years.
Happy Christmas.
Happy Hanukkah.
Happy Kwanzaa.
Happy.
A powerful young Jamie.
Let's do holiday.
See Ya.
Bye.